so in New Mexico the governor declared
that guns were illegal and if you
possess them you will be in trouble uh
there was a suggestion that would be a
misdemeanor but it may now be a citation
we'll see how it plays out and the
reason for this could be because a whole
bunch of dudes showed up with guns in
Albuquerque and said nah you can't do
this in fact the backlash has been so
severe that even Democrats even David
Hogg himself said you can't do this and
uh we were all really impressed and
surprised because apparently they they
don't remember what they said during
coven David OGG said that there's no
Public Health exception exemption to the
Constitution and uh during covet that's
exactly what they did but anyway the New
Mexico Governor tried to to ban guns by
decree and it's not working however
there are rumors circulated there's a
local paper I haven't been able to
verify this saying that a spokesperson
said those who defied the order and
oblique openly cared will be they will
have enforcement actions taken against
them but we will see if this plays out I
don't have a very good source outside of
this local paper but I don't want to be
smart they're a good name it's just uh I
want to make sure we're being very
carefully carefully careful here in
other news Joe Biden skipped the 911
memorial today and he's the first
president to do so uh it's shocking and
I I gotta be completely yes I'm I'm
personally offended by that there's this
really great story that I want to we'll
talk about when we get into when we get
into this about a man who sacrificed his
life and there were many many people who
sacrificed their lives but not only in
the short term by running back and into
those buildings to save people
the people who are doing cleanup after
the fact who had permanent lung damage
and cancer and and injuries and they
risked everything on that day to save as
many people as possible so the least
you'd think a president could do is just
be there in New York to say that you
know this this means something to us but
he didn't and uh that's that's just
offensive Donald Trump wants to want the
judge to recuse herself so we'll talk
about that but before we get into all
the news my friends head over to
timcast.com click the timcast irlx Miami
and you gotta come down to Miami hang
out with us we got a really a really
great show October 6th live it's Friday
we will be in Miami with Patrick Bett
David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates you'll
you'll have uh me and lucrutkowski as
well as Ian on stage hanging out we're
gonna have a bunch of free stuff free
products the event is spot the event is
sponsored by Public Square so we've got
a whole bunch of really awesome stuff to
hand out to everybody who does show up
we're gonna have merch t-shirts coffee
and we've got uh some big announcements
probably on that day that uh I think you
want to be there for we're going to be
doing we have a big bold plan
for uh well I'll keep it vague but
there's a big bold plan we have in place
that I think is going to be uh pretty
pretty dang awesome and I look forward
to seeing you there also while you're at
timcast.com click join us become a
member so you can hang out for the
members only uncensored show that will
be coming up at 10 pm tonight it's gonna
be a lot of fun not so family friendly
and you as members can call in and
submit questions so sign up today to
support our work and when you do support
our work
you're supporting all of all of our
cultural Endeavors and we've got some
big news coming up out of West Virginia
we're uh going to be producing this big
skateboard skate park Action Sports
thing and uh we've got some some new
property where we're going to be
hopefully as we move forward building
something truly awesome to expand the
culture and I really do appreciate all
of your support in helping us on our
mission so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel joining us
today to talk uh subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about this and
so much more is Libby Emmons that's me
it's her birthday it's my birthday and
here I am I'm Libby Emmons I'm with the
post-millennial and humanevents.com glad
to be here I'm totally going to be at
your show in October in Miami I'm really
stoked
to come hang out yeah we have a we uh I
mean I don't wanna I don't want to say
too much just yet because we have a
bunch of special guests who are going to
be there but um I'm I'm hoping the fresh
and fit dudes will be there uh because
they're in Miami already and we talk to
them uh you're gonna be there we have
there's actually more than just the
people on stage who are going to be
there so I think maybe we should we
should you know we'll put together a
list so you know because you could be
end up hanging out with a bunch of cool
people that you're fans of outside of
the show plus the Vulcan one was super
fun I had a great time with that that
was chaos yeah that was chaos at one
point you called me up on stage and I
didn't hear you because I was chilling
with Savannah Hernandez yeah I was like
just Libby's here at this point I mean
like it might it might get wider because
there's gonna be so many people at the
Miami show who are uh it's not just like
it's done Junior Patrick David Patrick
David met Gates but there's going to be
like I think 10 or 15 other people a
bunch of us are going we're also yeah so
you know and then we'll probably just
pull people up on stage because the
conversation is a conversation but uh
but happy birthday yeah thank you yeah
this is my birthday yeah
we got Hannah Claire hanging out hey I'm
Hannah brimlow I'm happy to be back I'm
really hoping that uh Libby will do her
impression of her grandfather at some
point today oh my grandfather used to
call and wish me a happy birthday yeah
yeah can I do it yeah you want to hear
it so my grandfather's from New York he
grew born and raised in New York he was
born in Little Italy downtown and uh he
used to call me on my birthday after 9
11 and he'd be like sweetheart I know
it's a terrible day
but happy birthday
we're so glad you're here to celebrate
I kind of loved it just because for the
sweetheart you know but
you know yeah thank you well I'm glad
you're here uh I don't feel like I don't
have to say it but I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm glad to be here Ian's
here too dude what your birthday was I
didn't know your birthday was September
11th so just now oh yeah it's my
birthday did it mess you up well it was
already messed up let's talk about
September 11th on the show a little bit
we're definitely gonna because of the
Joe Biden thing but I definitely we're
talking a little bit beforehand and it's
really interesting to hear your story
about I can tell you about my whole day
yeah we'll get into it it's it's I mean
ever ever it's the famous saying like
everyone remembers where where they were
when when 9 11 happened my mom has told
me about where she was when Kennedy got
shot I don't remember but she told me
about it yeah oh and it was your
birthday so there's the first question I
don't want to spoil it but immediately
asked a question and Libby was like yeah
I started laughing but we'll get into it
we'll save it we got surge hanging out
what's up guys I am back I'm ready for
this one you are Tim let's go let's go
this is awesome
is the coolest thing ever from kob4 gun
owners rally in Old Town to protest
Public Health order you know they don't
want to just call it what it is the
headline should read gun owners defy
unconstitutional and criminal action by
Governor but uh maybe a little bit
strong for me but I I think that's the
fair the fair headline you've got this
video we've got Ford Fischer as well
many people openly carrying in defiance
of the governor's decree
good for them and the police are
basically backing away from this they're
saying that not that they're not going
to enforce it the statement from the
sheriff was was effectively that but it
was a little tepid so we'll see
they say more than 100 people openly
carried guns in Old Town as they
protested Governor Michelle at Luan
grisham's recent controversial move on
Firearms you see they try very hard to
avoid calling what it is
we're not here to cause any issues we're
just here to you know express our
Amendment rights and you know it will go
from there it was a rally against part
of grisham's Public Health Emergency on
gun violence specifically the part where
she banned carrying guns either through
open or concealed carry uh permits in
Bernalillo County and the City of
Albuquerque for 30 days no
constitutional right in my view
including my oath is intended to be
absolute there are restrictions on Free
Speech there are restrictions on freedom
that's what she said
my jaw dropped for our Second Amendment
to be to be suspended it it's
unconstitutional we got to put it that
way a lot of people feel that way said
Derek now here's the funny thing about
no no rights are absolute yes it means
due process of law not I hereby decree
you can't keep in bear arms in defiance
of your own State's Constitution and
your uh your Federal Constitution our
Federal Constitution
so we this is the story that we uh we
got cheerful New Mexico's most populous
County rejects Governor's gun ban
calling it unconstitutional reject
because what does that really mean the
current rumor that we're hearing and I
think I have it here from the paper
I have I I don't know what this this uh
publication is I'm not familiar with it
uh I don't know how accurate this is all
I know is this is being circulated it
may or may not be true take it with a
grain of salt however in it
Carolyn's they say that they they
reached out it's uh the paper in
Albuquerque that's what's called the
paper reached out to Carolyn Sweeney a
Luhan Grisham spokeswoman who said the
order is being enforced and citations
will be forthcoming from the state
police to ensure officer safety we will
not be providing additional details at
this time so I'm wondering if the move
they make is to pull up videos of people
who were openly carrying and then
privately go after them so imagine this
someone goes to the rally and they're
openly caring legally but the governor
has issued a decree they're on camera
facial recognition whatever they know
who the person is they issue a warrant
for their arrest and under what you know
under what law or whatever it's not
going to be for open carrying open
carrying there's going to be some
violation like Defiance of Public Health
Emergency section whatever the cops are
going to show up to the guy's house and
say we've walked for your arrest for you
know Defiance of executive order and
let's list a bunch of charges none of
which will be having a gun
that the person is going to be like are
we talking about and the cop's going to
say listen man I don't know who you are
I don't know what you did I know you're
under arrest so while many people are
saying the cops won't enforce this cops
will defy it I'm like yeah but what
happens when some random 28 year old cop
is told we got a warrant for a guy on
disorderly conduct felony disorderly on
state grounds and he goes sounds good to
me they're gonna start getting arrested
but we'll see I'm glad to see that
people are standing up to this it's it's
it's it's blowing up in the in the
governor's face Democrats are angry
about it but you know well it should go
it should blow up in the governor's face
this is another one of these lead
through crisis situations we saw this
with Biden we saw this Kamala Harris was
talking about this they were listing off
you know this was pre-covered even they
were listing off
um Public Health emergencies they were
talking about climate change Public
Health Emergency racism then they threw
covet into the mix they threw guns into
the mix and it's like you were saying
like as soon as you declare something a
public health emergency they start
suspending all of our civil liberties
and you remember even during covid you
had sheriffs and police officers saying
that they were not going to enforce
lockdown orders but people were getting
arrested anyway you know there's still
people who get who who have been charged
with that stuff and been prosecuted and
that stuff stands yeah and I would say I
love 2A people like this idea that
there's just a bunch of them like openly
carrying guns and everything is fine
like you're not hearing anything about
any violence that came out of this rally
I think it's such an interesting display
because uh if the government of New
Mexico is taking such a drastic and
expansive interpretation of Public
Health Emergency it's cool to see them
say well we're just going to protest and
demonstrate publicly rather rather than
say well I'm scared of what will happen
I think that's uh the sort of only uh I
don't know white pill in this situation
the other thing too though is remember
in um in Lansing Michigan in April 2020
you had a lot of people showing up at
the Capitol say saying we are opposed to
lockdown orders we're not going to do
this anymore they went into the Capitol
and they were called White supremacists
you know these people are going to get
called names and the other thing too is
like even if they're out there today and
the sheriff says oh maybe we're not
going to prosecute you don't know like
they could come to your door in two
months there's people now getting
arrested for 9 11 they've arrested over
1200 people for that you don't even know
9 11 not 11. whatever it is not the
other times that is obnoxious to use
dates they actually there's only a
couple of people who were arrested now
for 9 11 and they haven't been
prosecuted so they're still hanging out
in Guantanamo and prosecutors are
looking at plea deals for those people
but don't worry we got all of the
January we have 9 11 in my head because
it's my birthday
I've heard stories of people who are on
the capitol on the capitol grounds
that were that nothing ever happened
right so like a year ago there were
stories people would say was like oh I
knew someone who was at that rally and
they were walking around the grass but
they never got charged arrested I
thought they'll shut up at your house
well and then they just arrested Owen
Shroyer uh they had arrested tomorrow
they're trying to sentence him to like
120 days he didn't go into the capital
he was hanging out outside and part of
the thing and yelling generic
anti-establishment like revolutionary
commentary and then the sentencing well
I think it's a death of tyrants yeah and
so the Democrats were tyrants I mean
yeah
they also referenced things that he said
on air yeah I mean
after yeah if you read the the statement
from the doj they say in the months
leading up and they said he he made
January 6th half I mean they are trying
to make another person they're pinning
this on uh and you know rightly so his
attorney has responded with uh you are
trying to use to violate his Free Speech
rights and to make this more than what
it is they also say you know he's been
on pre-trial like it's supervised
pre-trial uh supervision for the last
two years so surely he shouldn't have to
also go to jail but this is what people
in New Mexico need to think about as
well one I think it's good that people
are
Democrats are on board with rejecting
the governor's decree so they're
probably these people who protested
probably gonna be totally safe
if these rumors are true
it's going to get scary because it's not
going to be a cop showing up saying you
you defied the governor's order and
carried a weapon you're under arrest and
then the person films themselves they're
like look what's happening now it's
going to be like you have you have a
bench warrant for your arrest why what
did I do that's for the court I don't
know man all I know is I got I'm told
you got a warrant and you're coming with
me I've been rereading the trial the
Kafka novel and this guy gets arrested
and he gets put on trial and they never
tell him the charges right they never
tell him what he did wrong and he's
trying to navigate the court and figure
things out and trying to like understand
how he's being treated uh trying to
navigate having a job he doesn't want to
tell anybody that this is happening to
him because he's embarrassed and he's
ashamed every everywhere he looks and
the more he the more he digs into his
trial and what's going on the more he
realizes that like literally everyone is
against him everyone has been spying on
him this whole time
um
and I it just has seemed uh like the
exact right time to reread the trial and
the more I listen to it because I've
been doing it on audiobooks The More I
listen to it I'm just like Tang like
Kafka knew what he was talking about
exactly we're looking at this now what
is this political Kafka what year what
country was he from he was from the
Czech Republic then Czechoslovakia he
lived in Prague he was basically an
insurance clerk who was writing on the
side
um I don't know what his political
leanings were he was essentially
anti-authoritarian
it was like during the Soviet era it was
it was when was he writing what was it
like Franz Kafka 30 1880 1880 1925.
there you go Western's alive he's only
40. yeah I was reading him in high
school
um
because I was really intrigued by a
couple of his stories metamorphosis and
The Hunger Artist were the ones that
really I was like whoa what's that about
and then the castle but
um but yeah he was anti-authoritarian
and if you look at his work it's just
like this crushing State and there you
are just this individual trying to have
an existence you know and in many cases
just a quiet existence without being
bothered without being any you know in
trouble at all without having anybody
come at you and it's just the state
swirls around you eats you up and
destroys you I I think a lot of people
have this uh misunderstanding about how
the system works when it's working
against you I think a lot of people
especially people watch the show
probably get it but I feel like the
average person they assume that if you
do something wrong you know Cops show up
and they say you do something wrong they
don't realize that sometimes you're in
the wrong place at the wrong time and
you get arrested for no reason there's a
guy to Occupy Wall Street who this is a
hilarious Story by the way he is a
middle-aged guy wearing a suit with gray
hair and he is inside a bodega Frozen
don't know a corner store buying an
orange I think it was a Fanta
the police use that orange kettling net
they call it to wrap around protesters
so to stop people from leaving when they
say that's an unlawful assembly and
you're all under arrest the cops go from
one side of the building and they make a
half moon around all these people and
the door and the guy walks out of the
convenience store drinking his orange
Fanta on break from work and he's
confused like what's going on why am I
in this thing he can't go back inside
they're like no you can't come in and
then he goes to the cop and says hey I
was just in the store buying a drink and
they're like shut your mouth and he's
like I'm not a protester I'm just a guy
on break I'm drinking they're like
you're under arrest shut your mouth
most the cops holding holding the the
the the netting won't say anything he
has a supervisor they ignore him he got
arrested he got arrested for literally
drinking an orange Fanta because he
walked out of a store into the area they
had corralled and the police had anyone
inside this is under arrest even though
they got some guy who was just drinking
a soda doesn't matter and so he goes to
jail he can't tell his work what
happened and all I oh this is what I was
told right
uh he was at a meeting in the city
screaming at the top of his lungs to the
police about what they had done to him
and the cops just like we literally do
not care what you think it's a it's a
city of millions of people and you are
one guy with no Authority and no power
so you can shut your mouth you're
meaningless they didn't say that
literally but that's what they that's
basically it and they just paid off BLM
protesters who were torching cop cars
well there's millions of occupies yeah I
know but they just did this they paid
off protest they're not protesters
they're like militant BLM Riders they
paid them off millions of dollars
there's a lot of stories like that where
the police arrest random people there
was a guy named Alex Arbuckle who was
taking pictures of Occupy Wall Street
he's standing on the sidewalk when the
protesters get you know circled or
whatever and a cop walks up to him while
he's not part of the protest and on the
sidewalk away from the protest and
arrests him
he was a different officer was told to
sign for the arrest and fabricate a
statement as to why he should be
arrested and the fabricated statement
was that he was obstructing the roadway
like all the other protesters the funny
thing is this guy went down there to
tell the police's side of the story on
the protests because he felt it wasn't
being accurately portrayed and uh I was
live streaming everything that had at
the time
and I filmed the illegal arrest the
officer who lied under oath never got
any accountability never two officers
fabricated the charges against him and
this guy cold wake-up call the cops just
made it up I think the one of the
problems we faced with a lot of the with
a lot of what's going on with tyranny is
is density uh like a lot of the problems
that emerge that we complain about in
terms of weird Progressive cult-like
behavior is just density of cities and
then an inability for people to come
like how how you deal with 300 violent
protesters throwing bottles into rocks
at cops
well like this is a group of people do
this we gotta arrest them uh-oh there
were two guys in there who were wrongly
roped in what do you do do you then go
through it like where can we do like
what do you do check all the phones for
videos of everyone so they just say we
don't care yeah I think the problems of
corruption at the top is due to density
too because when you know everybody
you're working with all 60 of your your
people you have a personal relationship
with everybody you can make sure that
everyone's needs are met that if there's
a problem with one of them it can be uh
it can be you know dealt with but if
there's 300 million people that you're
trying to govern it just becomes numbers
man I mean that's what Lujan Grisham is
doing too right she's saying anyone who
is interested in having a gun is
potentially dangerous and therefore I'm
going to uh carry this out on all
citizens I mean it's a complete
overreach and that's similar to the
position the cops take we've decided
there's a crisis and so we don't care
about the Nuance let's think about it
this way
the the order that was given by Grisham
is that if there's like something like a
thousand deaths or it's like some
capacity like if there's a number of
deaths related to guns at this number
you can't have a gun there which
basically is Albuquerque and and
Bernalillo so think about it this way
for let's say for every 100 citizens you
have every year there's one gun murder
that's a lot yeah okay but hold on let's
let's say that there is a town of 100
people and every year one person dies in
a shooting
talking but one murder is not going to
shock the minds of every single of of
the Town they're going to be Iceland
they have like four murders a year and
as a substantially less people so the
issue is
when if if it's what I have to talk
about with the uh the scaling problem if
one per let's say 0.1 of your population
is killed in a gun in a in by violence
every year so let's say for every
thousand people one person dies No One's
Gonna blame guns they're gonna say this
murder is unconscionable
now let's say you have a million people
okay now all of a sudden you've got what
ten thousand I'm gonna do my math wrong
or a thousand
you have a thousand deaths now you ban
guns because it's a gun problem a
thousand people dying is terrifying even
though it's the same proportionality so
this is the problem of mass density in
these cities it may be that people are
dying probably dying at lower rates
percentage-wise due to gun violence than
ever before but there's more gun deaths
than ever before there's more people and
more guns and more media right in the
hands of the mother of the kid that was
killed or the cousin of the guy that got
shot like back in the day you'd get a
news report about it maybe well so
here's the other thing like police
blotter I remember I always checking
police blocks they give viral Twitter
posts but even under a million people
see and stuff that freaks people out
over and over and pre-2000 if someone
got shot they're gonna die you your
chances of getting paramedics there
you're running to find a pay phone when
I was a teenager I watched a woman have
some kind of stroke and I'm 16 no cell
phones I mean people at cell phones at
the time like but
right I had to run into a bank and it
was like I run into a bank and I was
like I need help and there's a guy
speaking it was excuse me we're in the
middle of me I'm like a lady just
collapsed and then they they'd stand up
and then they call 9-1-1 or whatever but
like if I had a cell phone like if it's
today I watch someone fall I throw my
phone right away right so the the you
know but that means you probably have
more people dying like in the 90s and
you could probably see you know
homicides going down you actually can
because of cell phones but now because
we have more and more people she's
justifying the amount of people as the
reason why to ban guns but also you know
criminals aren't going to care they're
going to carry guns anyway as always
that's always the thing well let's talk
about the go ahead oh I was gonna say
let's jump to the story about uh Owen
Shroyer this is uh this is a big one
Owen Shroyer's uh Owen Troy responds to
the doj sentencing recommendation
you know when I saw this story we know
that Owen Shroyer is being uh targeted
because of a speech he was on the
capitol grounds he did not go in the
building his charges are like
misdemeanor trespass of some sort
they want him to go to jail prison
federal prison for three months and the
the fact the factors in the sentencing
guideline recommendations were his
speech before during and after shocking
when I read what what his response was I
thought it was uh very important
considering what's going on
let me read for you from timcast.com
actually written by Hannah Claire
brimelow hey guys Owen schroyer has
asked the judge overseeing a sentencing
to go against the recommendation
submitted by the Department of Justice
while in DC shorty told a crowd of
people over a bullhorn the Democrats are
posing as Communists but we know what
they really are they're just tyrants
they're tyrants and so today on January
6 we declare death to tyranny death to
tyrants
the doj asked the court to consider that
Shroyer's conduct on January 6 like the
conduct of hundreds of other Riders took
place in the context of a large and
violent Riot that relied on numbers to
to overwhelmed oh typo the police
officers who were trying to prevent a
breach of the Capitol building
all right so here's here's where it gets
good and the response to the
government's proposed sentence Shroyer's
attorneys argue the prosecution is
taking direct aim at freedom of speech
quote it seeks to penalize Mr schroyer
for his viewpoints claiming apparently
that his views are relevant offensive
offense conduct that must be considered
in crafting a sentence sufficient but
not greater than necessary to punish the
crime to which Mr Shroyer pleaded guilty
a single misdemeanor count of entering
and remaining in a restricted building
or grounds in violation of 18 USC
section 1752 A1 says the responding
statement from Shroyer's team that says
it all
what was Shroyer charged with being in a
restricted area
that's it and for this they drafted up
this this recommendation saying his
speech on his show said the election was
stolen that he hates tyranny so he needs
three months since hold on hold on
what was he charged with Insurrection
was he charged with incitement no he was
charged with effectively trespass so in
what way is it relevant it's because
these people are are cultists it's
entirely political
and I think this is another uh
another grain of sand in the Heap of
evidence we know that what they're doing
to the January 6 uh individuals not all
of them but many of them and if not the
majority of them and people like Owen
Shroyer and Donald Trump and these
others is political persecution through
prosecution for political power
I think you're right I think uh
schroyer's experience is really
interesting because there's obviously
antipathy on on the part of the
government they they want him to be yet
another person who is dangerous and
therefore needs to be locked up and I
think ultimately it's really interesting
he's being represented by uh Norm patus
who also represented Joe Biggs and um
and zacharyles if I'm not mistaken uh
these are very different cases obviously
the proud boys were charged with
conspiracy and you can argue if that was
fair or right or not but in this case he
never entered the building he stood
outside and yelled a bunch of stuff and
they are saying therefore he deserves to
go to jail on this charge it it seems
like they will never let this Panic that
they manufacture die it's a totally
manufactured panic and it's interesting
too because
um a lot of the January 6 people who
have already been arrested detained
prosecuted charged sentenced were like
the littler people the people whose
names you don't know you know like the
grandmas from Illinois or whatever who
now don't really get a hearing you saw
sometimes they would come on Tucker
Carlson's show on Fox and they would
talk about it and they would talk about
what's going on with them but they were
you know they were people whose names
you didn't know and now they're using
all of the precedents all of the like
heavy-handed prosecution that they
staged against these smaller people who
you didn't know whose case is only
really Julie Kelly was following yeah
you know and they're using those same
precedents to go after people whose
names you do know and they're going to
use those same precedents that they're
doing now against Shroyer and the proud
boys and all those guys to go after
Trump because it's the same judge yeah I
mean chuken is the same judge and shukin
hates Trump has said that has her own
opinions and then they're using all of
this too to try and get Trump off the
ballot and I think it's very important
to note that no one has been charged
with Insurrection like that's not if you
go to a search it's just not there in
the in the in the doj documents of
people charged with
you know January 6th I want to jump to
the statement the doj made in their
quote when they said
that uh they have to consider that sure
is conduct like the conduct of hundreds
of other Riders took place in the
context of a large and violent Riot
Heavens Me Owen Shroyer yelled death to
tyrants shocking wow I'm I I wonder how
much prison time raps is gonna get for
literally telling people to go into the
capital and then being there right when
the barricade was torn down and they
gave Joe Biggs 20 years so Ray Epps
What's it gonna get 50
life's gonna get nothing you already saw
the Washington Post the New York Times
and everybody else coming out saying
like Ray Epps did nothing wrong it's
literally everybody else who did
something wrong even though we have
videos the one hero the one guy that we
have seen do you know doing the thing
that somehow I I think it's interesting
too like the cops that gave
um the shaman a tour around the capitol
I haven't heard anything about
disciplinary action happening for them
right like of course there is no Fallout
for people who you know whether we can
say it was mistaken or on purpose
facilitated actual things that then
people were saying who shot an unarmed
woman nothing and that's crazy I think
your point that they have been building
up to this for so long is so interesting
because often when I'm writing these
stories the the statement comes across
and it's from the doj that over a
thousand people have been charged in
connection with January 6 over 600 have
been sentenced in over 300 are in prison
at this moment and when I read that
sentence I am horrified I feel that way
because I obviously have one I have a
perspective on January 6 that you know
left wing me through me video doesn't
when they hear the same statistics that
over a thousand people are have been
charged that over 600 people have been
sentenced in that over 300 are in jail
they think good job we're getting them
but that's so interesting like in
Portland in the summer of 2020 they ride
it for over a hundred nights straight
they tried to burn down a federal
courthouse Donald Trump was like we
really should send in the National Guard
and the governor was like no no no we
hate you don't send in the National
Guard we would rather have our
Courthouse burn down and then you know
they tried to set fire to the mayor's
apartment building while there were
people in it yeah and this is all
totally fine and then we hit January you
know 6 2021 they call it this they call
it deadly riots it was literally one day
it was one day deadly Riot caused by the
police officer right also where everyone
went home by like what eight it was
literally one day and they talk about
you know people brought weapons there
were what tasers and a fire extinguisher
I love how they also say like they they
say oh there's no way that they would
have been able to overthrow anything
don't they understand how this
government thing works like you can't
just take the building and overthrow
everything and at the same time right
they act like that's what and today
there were leftist agitators occupying
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy's office
why are they not going to jail for 25
000 years I think you meant
insurrectionists insurrectionists we
always are going back and forth over
what words to use for these psychotic
people what those people were doing at
Kevin McCarthy's office just straight up
on the table is that legal
I don't I don't know I don't know
assuming everything's on the board and
that we're following the law legally to
go are you allowed to go into your
representative's office and sit there
and refuse to move even after they try
and tell you to leave well it's
trespassing it's it's for sure
trespassing I mean how did you know I
don't know they wanted they wanted more
foreign aid for AIDS medications so
they're trespassing to make a noise for
sure they were sitting there locking
arms refusing to leave yelling yelling
about Kevin McCarthy I guess the answer
is no it's not legal it's trespassing
yeah it seems pretty respiratory to me
also isn't that some of the risks of
protesting right like if you're choosing
to protest you obviously know there's a
potential that you could you know be on
property or not supposed to I mean
nobody protests from their own living
room right they used to be getting
arrested was good publicity back in the
day it was a good way to get the news
Jane Fonda was getting arrested like
every Friday or whatever it was when she
was doing her climate protest outside of
the a bunch of a bunch of celebrities
like to get arrested when it's
environmentalist related but then we
have this example where it's like we had
One Singular day and now we can never
let it go and again I know this morning
they fetishize right but where are the
black lives matter protest arrest right
what happens when you see what happens
to them they get let off they get very
short sentences or they just get let off
all together and settlements from the
city settlements from the city yeah we
did a story Hannah Nightingale at post
millennial did a story last week about
the huge uh amount of money that cities
have been paying out to BLM and antifa
militant activists
um compared to how much damage was done
it was like two billion dollars in
Insurance damage the most expensive
riots in American history in 2020 and
cities have been paying out millions and
millions of dollars to people for having
arrested them one guy in La got paid out
like millions of dollars for being shot
with a rubber bullet now do you remember
the summer of 2020 it was like you know
defund police you have to use non-lethal
crowd control so they use non-lethal
crowd control and the city still has to
pay out millions of dollars what the
hell is that
because you're not supposed to be
against that narrative where it's okay
to be against whatever they have demons
I mean even when you look at this now a
lot of the mainstream coverage of it has
dropped the fact that like Trump held a
peaceful rally where he talked and then
later said everyone go home don't go
there they just drive to completely they
act like people randomly showed up in DC
to Riot and that's obviously not what
happened but that's the narrative that
they would like that's the history they
would like to preserve that uh the BLM
Riders were just you know peacefully
protesting the BLM writers the BLM
writers were
um uh
involved in a public health emergency
yes remember because racism was a bigger
Public Health Emergency than Colvin I'm
never forgiving the whole coveted thing
I'm never getting over that on January
6th there was some violence obviously
people some people rioted smashed stuff
up for sure
was a riot and saying other side of the
building owners on the other side where
there were no rides my understanding is
that where Owen was with Alex Jones it
was just people walking around
they were not at the area where people
were smashing and throwing things at
cops and stuff I trespassing I get it
technically I guess I can I can wrap my
mind around it but for him to say
Democrats are tyrants death to kill them
kill the tyrants like is that what he
said that he said these people are the
tyrants Now kill the tyrants that's kind
of like saying kill those people I I I
don't disagree to it but the way you
phrase it has a bit unfair he said he
did say Democrats are posing as
Communists but we know what they are
there's tyrants death The Tyranny death
to tyrants so I agree with what you're
saying but he the way you said it was a
little bit it wasn't
um like an imminent threat to violence
he wasn't calling like I want you to go
this name this person at this place kill
he wasn't saying that so it wasn't
illegal to say that but if you say that
in front of a mob and then the mob gets
angrier I mean but it is like a oh
someone rid me of this priest right
right but but regardless uh
what's he charged with just trespassing
in which case this is immaterial to his
sentence you're right this speech is not
relevant yeah right and uh unless he's
charged with making threats but oh won't
someone rid me of this priest it's not
illegal you can argue irresponsible but
they're they're doing this because
they're also doing it to Trump like if
you look at the indictment in Georgia it
it references tweets that he made like
oh the Georgia ballot counting is being
broadcast on oan and Bonnie Willis says
that's evidence of a conspiracy
it doesn't make any sense I think the
fact if you look at the like hundreds of
counts
I think the fact a lot of them are
social media posts the the D.A and
Georgia did not indict loffler Purdue
and Graham shows it's entirely political
to go after Trump's Administration the
grand jury voted to indict these sitting
members or or at the time these members
of the of of the Senate and uh D.A
didn't do it why well it doesn't serve
her political purposes in any way
the D.A could still bring the charges
the grand jury voted to indict right but
it looks like you're just going after
the Trump Administration and his lawyers
purely political well because they want
to say that his campaign was a was a
criminal conspiracy well we saw you saw
that post from Julie Kelly on Twitter
that she was uh I think she was with
enrichitario
somebody was yeah and Enrique was saying
that they tried to get him to claim that
take a deal where he says he was working
with Trump or Trump told him to do it
wasn't it Kara Castro Nueva at Gateway
is that who said that I saw a tweet from
Judy Kelly yeah that he was he was
apparently told that when they arrested
him say that Trump you know was working
with you he told me you know he told you
to do something that effect and we said
no they were like then you're gonna go
away for the rest of your life and they
did for like the I.T worker right at uh
Mar-A-Lago what they threw they flipped
the I.T worker at Marlo it has now who's
turning on Trump it's really amazing to
me that there are some people who have
families have children and they look at
a burning building
and they hear a little girl scream help
and they say I am going to run in that
building Lord help me I will save that
little girl knowing they may die and
leave behind their children to be
fatherless and their wives to be widows
but they know what the right thing is to
do and then there are people who are
told
well
lock you up
you bet do as you're told and they are
completely unwilling to make any degree
of sacrifice or or stand up for anything
they fall over they fold like cheap
suits let's jump to this story this next
story
from Newsweek Joe Biden commemorating 9
11 in Alaska
Sparks backlash isn't that where the
third plane crashed yeah the the
mysterious yeah
the lion was on it that's how Joe Biden
died Joe Biden did not go to New York
for the 911 memorials the first it's the
first uh president to skip it I think
what I don't know if this is true I saw
a tweet it said that uh or an exposed
I'm sorry said that um the response was
22 years after Pearl Harbor president
stopped going to Hawaii
yeah okay so uh I take offense to this
um they also take offense to this and
when you read the stories of 9 11 and
and most of us have read them to a great
degree especially the people who are
watching because some people have read
too many stories about 9 11 and some
people have read a healthy amount to
better understand what happened how it
happened and there's a lot of wild
things out there I think most of us
we've read quite a bit and you learn
about the heroism
um my uh uh uh what's the what's the
word um
but uh shout out I'll just say that to
Jon Stewart for standing up for the 9 11
First Responders who are not getting
these oh he did that a lot right and and
it's brilliant because the men who
rushed when when people were running
away
rightly so there were people who ran
towards knowing what they had to do
knowing that they could leave their
children behind to have no father no
mother no family but they had to save as
many people as they could
and Joe Biden wasn't even commemorating
9 11. it's unfair to say that he did
what was he doing where he stopped in
Alaska is a typical refueling port for
Air Force One what really happened in my
opinion he was traveling back from
Southeast Asia and stops to refuel and
they were like well you might as well
say something and I was like oh okay
yeah sure yeah Kamala Harris went to New
York instead that's an embarrassment
she's an embarrassment she's a horror
she should have absolutely no place near
the White House ever under any
circumstance and she typically doesn't I
mean the Joe Biden Administration does
not engage with Kamala that much she's
so unpopular she was in charge of the
Border we never hear from her so to send
her in his stead is like saying that's
how much we don't care about this right
but also they try and get everyone to
say the Biden Harris Administration
that's what the press secretary says
Biden Harris I refuse to allow that
that's because we're going into an
election year and they're trying to be
like no no we have a woman of color on
the ticket so we're better it's just
disgusting yeah she is absolutely
horrifying I want to give a shout out to
spike Cohen for this tweet which I read
and it's very difficult to read and I
pulled up the Wikipedia page for the man
he wrote about Ray rascorla and uh
reading this story
brings me to tears and fills me with
rage at the same time that Joe Biden
doesn't care
then there's arguments about like well
but he had to give the speech in Vietnam
or whatever it's like you do not
schedule things that interrupt you
showing up to New York for 9 11 Memorial
whatever whatever your thoughts about 9
11 the people posting World Trade Center
7 all day it was trending regardless the
people died that day thou people died
afterwards people were sickly afterwards
dogs died lives were sacrificed and this
guy uh Rick
Rick roscorla has one of the most
incredible
stories I've ever read
I'll give you the simple version
security guard work of the World Trade
Centers it's concerned about a terror
attack potentially hitting the Trade
Centers has an assessment done they find
that there is a huge risk in the
basement a few years later some dude
tries to blow up the Trade Center by
doing exactly what they were warned
about he gets mad he begins these drills
every three months saying evacuations
why is he worked for Morgan Stanley's
security and they they had they were the
largest occupants of the South Tower
when 9 11 happened the North Tower gets
hit he immediately goes to everyone says
we practice for this we're getting out
but on the pa the Port Authority said to
stay at your desks he calls his best
friend and says that sobs are telling us
to stay I'm getting my people out of
here
only I believe 13 of the 2700 employees
at Morgan Stanley died because this guy
had a plan he was he was preparing for
for the risks thought ahead and he had
other people's lives in his mind not his
own so after they evacuated people when
the first plane hit they had 17 minutes
before the before the South Tower was
hit he got out almost every single
person and then he went back inside
and they never saw him again and he told
his wife on the phone that you know if
she never sees him again he loves her
and she gave him everything ever wanted
and you hear stories like that and it's
not the first story we've ever we've
ever heard
there's so many stories and I hear a
story like that and I hear a story about
all the First Responders that Jon
Stewart was defending and this is what
gets me so angry at the people who would
uh reject I I think the 911 First
Responders should have been given a
million dollars a year for the rest of
the year for the rest of their lives and
so many other people in this country
considering how much wealth we have
and you hear stories like this and you
hear stories of the dudes who rushed in
full speed never to be seen again
leaving behind families the people who
are victims who died in this the people
standing at the edge of the of the
molten steel and the burning building as
it sprays out the people who had to live
for decades with damaged lungs and
cancer and the least you can do Joe
Biden is show up literally the minimum
is just showing up I'm pissed man what
gets me one of the things that bothers
me the most is that those people that
went back into the building should be
alive because buildings like that are
not supposed to fall down from Office
fires and that's what they thought they
all thought it the firefighters knew
going in they knew their risk was
burning smoke chemicals there's
potential for explosions if there's gas
stored somewhere not the building would
would collapse on everybody they all
knew the buildings would stay up that's
why they went in they believed they
believe funny how knowledge can can
change like that well it's an amazing
it's amazing too how fragile
civilization is how can just you know
crumble everything you can believe about
it you can believe that the you know
steel i-beams are going to stay forever
but it's all just gonna crumble yeah and
it crumbles quickly
you know I feel like our civilization is
crumbling rather quickly at this point
we built it up so high
you know it was so big and now it's just
like crumbling when I see stories like
this though
um
I mean what an amazing an incredible man
to to do this to know to not worry about
what the authorities are saying to know
himself what's important and to go for
that you know so often now people just
believe what they're told and there's no
reason to believe what you're told you
think you have to think for yourself in
every single circumstance
um and it's just like clear the more
things that come up that it turns out we
can't trust what we are told and we've
there was so much we were told that we
believed you know well and we see so
many examples of people who are given
jobs to protect other people failing I
mean I think about the Uvalde school
shooting when the school resource
officer wasn't there and then this guy
is like I am the head of security and I
am going to take it so seriously
we need it we need him everywhere and
it's interesting because he wants to
read that uh read that quote I can read
it uh he I will get emotional short
reading this but
um he called wife Susan and said stop
crying uh I have I have to get these
people out safely uh if something should
happen to me I want to know I've never
been happier you made my life and I
think that's so crazy that like
this man was on the phone with his wife
it would have been so easy to be like I
got a bunch of people out I'm gonna run
up the street and he said like I am
going on my way home yeah I mean how
much would you think he wanted to be
with his wife in those last moments
right and even this is like he's Welsh
and I find this like to be very like UK
to me this idea that he's his wife is on
the phone she knows what's about to
happen she knows it's a risk and his
response is stop crying like we have a
job to do and we're gonna do it and
think about our current generation
think about the people we have today at
Uvaldi
man there was a post also from Ryan
gudurski talking about his uncle yeah
that was really powerful which was
really powerful his Uncle Pete who was
going in he thought his niece was in the
building and he kept going in to try and
get her out and and it turned out she
wasn't even it turns out she wasn't even
there but he kept going in and finding
somebody else and bringing them out and
then he'd go back in and he'd find
somebody else and bring that and he just
kept going back in to bring people out
and I remember that I remember that day
uh
because I mean I was in Philadelphia I
wasn't even in New York and it was your
birthday and it was my birthday but um
you know New York is always New York is
where my grandparents were born my
mother was born in New York uh
eventually my son was born in New York
but like
um I remember watching Rudy Giuliani
on TV because what happened was everyone
wanted news out of New York so all the
channels in Jersey and Philadelphia just
tuned into like the New York local
news like with New York won right so we
were all just watching New York one and
Rudy Giuliani like
um came on and he started talking about
it and what was going down and he
started he started talking about how
alternate side of the street parking
would be suspended
so for those of you who are not you know
super familiar with parking in New York
they clean the streets and so every
couple days you got to move your car to
the other side of the street so they can
lean the street and Giuliani started
talking about alternate side of the
street parking would be suspended and I
I was like super emotional feeling I was
like New York is still New York
Rudy giuliani's in charge
he's you know he's gonna
is Gonna Save the city again you know
and he did uh in a lot of ways
um but yeah the the people who did that
and later talking to my boss I worked
for this architecture company and my
boss was telling me his kids went to
school downtown and he lived in Brooklyn
and he walked a
he walked across the bridge everyone's
like running across the bridge trying to
get to Brooklyn everyone's like fleeing
downtown and he's walking the other way
to go get it to like go find his kids
and his kids his kids were okay and he
found them
um another person I know uh just was
like ended up writing a one-man show
called walk North and he had been
downtown and he just started like
walking North and like you know
everybody he ran into people just being
like do you guys does anyone need a
bathroom you could come to my apartment
does anyone need water like what does
anybody need you know my buddy is
walking North that morning after the
plane set same similar situation to get
Uptown and then there's people were
screaming that there's another plane
coming and they all just thought that it
was no one knew what was happening we
were under attack from all angles they
would scream panicked and run into
buildings and hide and stuff like that
no other plans ever came after the
second plane hit everything changed when
the first plane hit it was was this a
was this an accident right that's what I
thought first yeah something like wow
what could have happened love is a bill
who knows and then the second plane hit
and it was clear and the stories I heard
from some people just similar to what
you were saying no the day was not over
I mean World Trade Center seven
collapsed at what 5 PM that day
something like that something like that
so I mean if if you're in New York and
after you know it's 10 a.m and this all
this is going down and then later on in
the day all of a sudden another building
just collapses
shattering in the middle and just
falling straight down without even being
hit by a plane who knows any building
could have just fallen down that was the
like you said earlier how fragile things
are in life and things and I I believe
that but I also believe that steel
skyscrapers are not fragile and that yes
life is fragile but life can also be
destroyed by outside forces if you're
not paying attention and just like the
United States was taking over in 1913 by
the this Federal reservist corporate
fascist system I feel like our our
buildings were blown up dude World Trade
Center seven does not just fall down on
its own unless its structures are blown
out who blew out the supports who why
didn't World Trade Center one two fall
on your free fall hoopla the supports
well the city also changed the way that
buildings were inspected so my
grandfather was in engineer and he would
like inspect buildings and the way that
he used to inspect buildings would he
would go up inside buildings and he
would check it out he would look at
everything he would you know see
everything he could possibly see he
would go up into all the different nooks
and crannies of the buildings and figure
out what was going on with it and the
city changed the rules of how you
inspect buildings so that no longer did
you have to go up into the building but
you could just stand in a building
somewhere else with a telescope and look
at the building from there
and look at it that way and my
grandfather was just like this is
ridiculous this is not how we fix
buildings and he was going up in
buildings being like I can see from here
that gargoyle is going to fall off of
you know whatever he was like going up
into the Chrysler Building and all this
stuff looking at it from all the angles
being like this is how you got to fix
your building your building is in danger
and but they changed the way that they
looked at the buildings they changed the
inspection methods and they made it they
made it worse they made it substantially
worse when do they do that I don't
remember exactly I knew you were gonna
ask me and I decided to tell you the
anecdote about my grandfather anyway
sweetheart but I know that um they did
change it and they changed it
substantially long enough ago I think
there's a a simple truth
the government did not tell you the
truth about what happened on 911 and I
don't care what the media writes about
me their morons if you think the United
States government being attacked or
whatever you think happened is going
let's let's hop into the assumption
that that everything about they said is
true that would mean that the US
government revealed to the world quite
literally how the Pentagon got attacked
that's crazy I'm not gonna do it they'll
tell you what they can tell you but
there's a thing called classified and
top secret and if you think that after
we got attacked on 9 11 the government
was like here's all of the secrets about
what happened oh come on so you know
it's funny when Vivek ramaswamy says
we're learning now about you know the
Saudi involvement or whatever and they
try to make them look like a conspiracy
theorist you really think that the
government just like Declassified
literally everything no there's there's
probably a bunch of documents that even
Trump knows and he was like oh wow
didn't know that happened but they're
not gonna tell you I remember at the
time so I remember at the time
um because after after 9 11 the rents
went down in New York and I was like oh
as soon as I get a job in New York I'm
moving to New York which is what I did
um but I remember when then it was the
Patriot Act which is of course one of
the most egregious violations of
American civil liberties in the history
of a country and it's still in effect
you know it's basically warrantless
surveillance of Americans uh what they
did in reaction to a global you know a
threat from outside of the country is
they decided to surveil Americans more
you know and now we have the doj that
says the biggest threat in the United
States is domestic terrorism
um that's crazy it's crazy and it
started with the Patriot Act and I
remember my theater group we started
doing protest pieces about the Patriot
Act
um that were like uh you know wiretapped
phone conversations from the Oval Office
like making fun of George Bush because
of course we hated him and then
and then it was March 2003
George Bush founded the Department of
Homeland Security which now has like
some 240 000 employees it's a huge
Department they're dismantling the
border with their huge department but he
launched that on March 1st 20 2003 and
then March 19th was the invasion of Iraq
and I remember like being like we're
invading we're invading a rock this was
Saudi like we're invading Iran what are
we doing why is this even happening then
we go into Afghanistan which again any
student of History can tell you it's a
really bad idea to go try and fight a
war in Afghanistan that never works out
for anybody like that just never works
out why are we doing that and then Obama
was like oh I want to be president I'm
going to put more money into Afghanistan
and I was like well I can't vote for you
you're a war mongering crazy person like
we obviously can't do this and we just
kept going right down this road we
learned absolutely nothing unless that
was the plan all along was to create a
you know domestic surveillance state
where we just fund Wars to line the
pockets of presidents probably yeah I
think that was good American like free
speech and stuff it's okay but if you're
a rich corporatist it doesn't really
matter like you don't have free speech
in your corporation you run the show
right so someone pisses you off they're
gone and I don't think this idea of like
you can say whatever you want is even
like jives with his global banking uh I
don't know who who blew up those
buildings who who lined explosives that
blew the supports out on one and two
um
I I don't know I and to hear that there
were Saudis involved but that wasn't in
the mainstream as freakish uh how how
deep do you want to go there's less well
it's thermite in the dust well let's
let's go crazy on the members only show
we'll go absolutely just off the rails
as far as we can go but I wanna I wanna
talk I want to keep it a bit more uh
topical because we have the story from
the post millennial
Biden said he was at Ground Zero on the
day after 9 11. Congressional records
show he was on the senate floor I I
utterly despise this man in he is the
worst he is so awful it's amazing how
bad and awful he is no no like he's a
liar he's committed bribery okay here's
the here's the here's the post here's
the quote Ground Zero New York I
remember standing there the next day and
looking at the building I felt like I
was looking at the gates of hell it
looked so devastating here's him on the
senate floor on 9 12 at 1 45 p.m now
let's play a game do you think it's
lying or do you think it's dementia do
you think he doesn't know and he's
trying to factor a little bit I went up
a little bit of both yeah sure it's not
crazy sure nature versus nurture well
it's both you know do you think he's
just surrounded by people who are like
yeah tell that story sounds good man no
back in the day when he was young when
there was no internet and you couldn't
pull the videos he could say anything
did he go there within like three weeks
after there was a senate delegation on
September 20th so he was like the next
day in his mind he's like
the next day it was the next week it's
the same thing it was the next two weeks
yeah I don't know if he was part of that
thing then dementia makes more sense
well and also it's more interesting if
he's been lying his entire career which
we of course we know he has dementia I
have both Clips in it can you just
scroll down both clips here's the one
what the hell there's a link
you see you see let me when we're using
the post millennial and we we give a
shout out to you uh but here's what's
interesting is that you know we just had
the other day Kamala Harris saying she's
ready to take over
and then but why would she need to tell
us that but then she's the one at the
911 memorial and Joe Biden ain't here
yeah why because maybe he can't stay
awake long enough
well he did say I couldn't meet with the
Chinese president because I have to go
to bed or something like that oh wow
they were like talking about he avoided
the question by like joking loose
mainstream terms there for and Gavin
Newsom said he's not gonna run because
Kamala Harris is next in line but that
doesn't mean anything right like he says
that now and everyone's like see look
he's respecting the office but then you
know Kamala Harris he would run if he
could do it fast food restaurant and
then quits who knows she gets a job in
Academia where everyone who burns out in
politics goes uh no we I mean we talked
about the possibility I think what's
crazy about the The Joe Biden Ground
Zero thing is first off open lie that
anyone could fact check also when Trump
has told a story about you know watching
the towers fly in like the planes fly
into the towers from his apartment and I
pulled it today the Washington Post had
this big fact-checking ball he said he
told the story here and then he said he
used a telescope and then he did
whatever like but no one is going to
issue a correction other than you know
respectful people at the post-millennial
right what is this that everyone can
pretend like Joe Biden is just saying
the truth all the time but anything
Trump does they are willing to tear down
and it's right there on C-Span there's a
photo of trump on the ground afterwards
during like recovery efforts and then
there's a fact check where it's like he
did not go down to 911 to and I was like
he's literally there they use
technicalities to be like this is what
they always do is say did Donald Trump
go down to to the World Trade Center
wreckage to help recover
on Sunday
2015. it was Monday you're right no
false Monday at four it was actually
Sunday at 3 17 right it was Tuesday it
was Tuesday right did you see the video
of him being like who set the bombs
there were bombs that went off who said
Trump said that yeah he went and and in
20. like the day the day after like he's
down at the at the wreck he's like I've
got 100 guys in there working right now
I'm headed in to give him moral support
I want to know and that's different
clips of him being like there were bombs
there were firemen were like bombs went
off boom boom boom boom boom and then
the building just comes down Trump knew
he was there he's like what these steel
skyscrapers do not just fall out of
office well we'll talk about that in the
members you sure will no nuts I think
one of the craziest things and I think
Trump is representational this is when
he talks about 911 he talks about it
with you know a gravity that we're
obviously not seeing from Joe Biden
right I mean Joe Biden Trump's Hometown
it's Trump Hometown he feels it really
deeply and I think it it reminds me of
because I grew up in Connecticut so you
know we did like everyone got bust home
from school it was a big deal I I was
very young so like I don't have all the
clearest memories of it but you know
four years especially growing up in this
region you know people who have stories
are like oh yeah my my Dad was supposed
to have a meeting there that day and
then he didn't or like my mom did this
that and the other and you know whatever
you know people are affected by it the
one that I think of the most is uh
someone I knew had a a son who was in
high school at the time they could see
the buildings coming down from his high
school and he was staying with a
classmate and the family friend's son is
uh Catholic so he said a prayer and then
he crossed himself and his friend was
like went home to his dad and said you
know I wish we had something like that
because I I in moments of these complete
Terror how does anyone respond and I
wish I had a way to just like express
how I was feeling and I find this really
interesting because rather than
acknowledge the gravity of the situation
and the fact that so many people had
this moment where they thought are we
going to be okay we collectively to then
decide like Trump is wrong because he
didn't go down when we said he did
meanwhile it's okay for Biden to say
well after 20 years I've decided it's
not worth remembering this I mean this
impacted people so profoundly that maybe
he should have just been honest I've
been like but yeah we had to refuel on
the way home from Asia I couldn't make
it but even then it seems crazy where
the generation you're targeting with
votes don't remember so it's not just
people who are born
in 2001 or after
it's the people who were born in 1997.
who don't remember I remember I mean I
remember after my mother was a
Securities lawyer she's retired but I
remember after after this day I saw her
a little while later cleaning out her
Rolodex we used to have this thing it
was called a Rolodex you'd put phone
numbers in it on paper yeah and it would
be a hole in it and it would be like a
loose leaf binder if anyone knows what
that is anyway she was literally tearing
names out of her Rolodex
um people who had not only died but
anyone who had an office in the Trade
Center because that was also useless
that was their work number and work
address yeah wow
um and that was a that was a very
chilling moment for me and I was like
what are you doing she's like none of
these people work here anymore and some
of them are not alive and I was like
okay wow which is great the fact that
she's crazy it's been an afternoon doing
that wasn't it like uh Seth MacFarlane
was supposed to be on one on one of the
planes
I think that's the story uh I don't know
for sure yeah and then something
happened yeah
the you got a call from mayor Willie
Brown or something no I'm kidding
now Willie Brown apparently said he got
a phone call or something like that well
I I will say we're gonna we're gonna go
ham on the members only we're gonna go
ham I mean we can because we got a bunch
of other news stories yeah it says he
missed by about 10 minutes missed flight
11. he and Mark Wahlberg were supposed
that's what I was thinking of there are
crazy there are children who are growing
up having never been without TSA like
yeah you know I never never traveled
before that like I I that's crazy it
doesn't make any sense but at the same
time 20 years is a really long time
there are kids born after 9 11 who only
know about life under the patriarch with
these these intensities but I I never
flew
before TSA you know when I was a kid uh
my parents my dad lived in Boston and I
grew up and I lived with my dad and my
mom lived in New York she lived um 165
West 66th Street and I used to fly back
and forth on the Eastern Airlines
shuttle Eastern also doesn't exist I am
so old you guys anyway I used to fly
back and forth between my parents and my
dad would like at Logan Airport he would
walk me to the gate and like see me off
and sometimes he would walk me onto the
plane and in movies the people are
waiting outside the Gateway and I used
to have it and my mom would be like
right outside the right outside the
plane when I got off the plane she would
be right there and then there was this
weird time when like all the
unaccompanied minors got lost by the
Airlines and that was really weird
um for hours no one knew where and I
remember being like in a big room at an
airport with like hundreds of kids yeah
just like all of us sitting there for
tape I worked at O'Hare when I was 18
until I was 20. and so this is just four
years you know after 9 11. and I talked
to the guys who worked there who had
been there when it happened and they
said this is what I was told by a
handful of guys that after it happened
within you know 15 or so minutes there
were guys in suits with rifles standing
on the tarmac and then and that's nuts
yeah they were alive how'd they get
there well I mean there's there's
they're there serious law enforcement at
airports so I'm sure when they were like
we have a terror thing attack happening
the airport send out the the dudes to go
on lockdown and they're like they're men
with guns standing outside in the tarmac
looking around keeping everyone away
trying to figure out what's going on I
was in New York like just a like a week
later or so after 9 11 and there were
guys just standing on street corners
like army guys in Greenwich Village with
like huge guns and I remember just being
terrified like there's crazy army guys
standing here with guns all down in the
West Village like that's nuts I worked
there I I moved to New York September
5th six days later they came down the
buildings and then I started working
messed up Ground Zero like October or
13th or something a month later I
started working there it was all
militarized it was like like devastating
Nation kind of windows were blown out
and the buildings all nearby and like at
the time I was like well I guess that's
what happens when buildings fall down I
didn't consider the projectile force
from the bombs going off I'm blowing out
the supports apparently that's why
wake up went flying out the side
according to the official report the
pressure from the pancaking effect
forcing air out the windows they got you
the official report nist National
Institute of science do you remember
this does not explain all the all the
the portable phones that they just set
up and like parked you remember that I
never used one no but they were there
I don't I don't know if the nist report
discussed seven which one Center seven
did it
um yeah I think it did but I haven't
read much about that I don't know if the
nist report does they talk about how the
building seven pancaked and then no no
no no no no no no no no they give some
half um no no you're talking about one
and two I'm saying World Trade Center
seven was where the the propane tanks
exploded after fires got out of control
causing it to to crump his propane that
blew up the entire something like
something that's I'm saying I'm saying
the official official official statement
on World Trade Center seven I believe is
debris from Trade Centers one and two
caused fires in World Trade Center seven
which burned out of control so funny
because of the chaos and limited
resource there's no firefighters
resulting in like you know like stored
gas tanks bursting or something like
that which then started weakening
various portions of the building causing
it to just crumple and then fall yeah
there's a digital
um simulation of the of the building
crumpling and they only show the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology only show like a portion of
the phone you know but then it doesn't
really explain why near Free Fall we're
gonna we're going to
get in all that at the members only so
go to timcast.com click join us become a
member and then in one hour we're gonna
have a very interesting conversation I
imagine about
um
unofficial uh beliefs I'll put it that
way and um you know we'll get into it
but I want to talk about the topical
stuff that we do have so we'll say that
for the members only
ladies and gentlemen we've got some
schadenfreude for you
from the Oregon uh from or Oregon live
Nike to permanently close northeast
Portland Factory Store why because Nike
went to the city and said we need cops
and the city said no we're sorry you're
dealing with safety challenges let me
see if I can find this it's a really
here we go look at this
wait mayor Ted wheeler said he was very
disappointed with the news of Nike's
community store closure and that his
team in city had worked tirelessly
tirelessly and in good faith with Nike
for almost a year to offer Creative
Solutions to their safety challenges
that's what they call it when mobs raid
your store when far left extremists set
fire to property all around your city
over whenever someone's safety Channel
says they're doing something in good
faith that makes me feel like it's it's
it's full of it like that they're full
like they're just making that up you
don't need to tell me it's in good faith
if you tell me that it's like your your
virtue signaling and it's not really in
good faith this is yeah this is one of
many stores that has been leaving
Portland
um Andy know who's with post-millennial
it keeps reporting on this because he's
been he's been writing about this for
years what's going on with antifa and
the militants and like the horrible
people who just want to destroy Portland
and this one we got the story for the
person the last thing if I just pulled
this up on my phone we're gonna we're
gonna lay it Katie worked on this yeah
multi-layered shot in freuda a guy who
said quote please smash all my windows
if it will be a step toward change has
announced that he must shut down his Tap
Room wait do you see the quote where he
says we were successful in every way
except financially
[Laughter]
so this is a leftist Portland business
whose owner advocated for the city's
destruction announces closing his tap
room after suffering significant
financial losses since that time the
owner of Reverend's Net's Hard Cider on
Southeast 35th Division Street
identifies as he him on social media
thanks Andy and he's always very good
pronouns he's permanently shuttering the
doors to his Tap Room the taproom's
beverages are are a former Staple in the
Progressive City now struggling with
surging crime homicides and business
closures following the Summer of Love
that's what Jenny Durkin called it the
mayor of Seattle at the time the summer
yeah she said the summer of love that's
right what a where did he say that
we succeeded everywhere but financially
it's in there I know because I I
reviewed the story
it's in there somewhere nope why is what
happened to it
it's a great quote if it's real oh there
it is there it is
we've done so many things and made
thousands of ciders we were successful
in every way but Financial there it is
I would assume but I guess not for
everybody well it is apparently because
he's closing his business he has now
failed to make to keep his business open
dude because he failed financially uh
business is fake business is fail okay
I'm not I don't want to rag on someone
smash all my windows if it will be a
step toward change I'm not going to rag
on someone because they went out of
business right businesses fail all the
time it's sad people try they don't make
it but my dude you advocated for your
business to fail I'm proud of you and I
want to say I congratulate you on your
success yes yes change was made you're
right indeed not at the cash rate yes if
if he said that smashing out his windows
will make a step toward change he got
exactly what he wanted so he was right
he succeeded did he thinks
through his window and then come in and
be like thank you so much I'll buy a
beer or like whatever he that he's
selling people always so ridiculous
that's what people always think they
always think like oh I'm I'm on board
with you so you will spare me and there
have been a number of stories that we've
reported on of like far leftists who
have small businesses who advocate for
BLM and antifa and then are surprised
when like I think one woman got killed
in a in a robbery and her family was
like no but we she wouldn't want anyone
to go to prison for this and it's like
they literally killed the woman remember
remember the comic from Shen where he
was like my bike got stolen but I
imagine the guy who stole it is happier
to have it than I am to lose it so the
world so total happiness and crazy it's
like ridiculous that guy who stole your
bike didn't think twice about it and
hooked it for 20 bucks he's not happy at
all he doesn't care he's maybe high now
so maybe he's happy there's this NPR
story from a while ago where they said
some businesses in Portland OR different
cities would hang like black lives
matter stuff in in hopes too during the
chat right thing in hopes of like not
not being attacked or not losing their
business and it was not a guarantee they
were just needing to Signal it even if
they didn't believe it uh I mean this
guy is such a character I wonder what
he'll do next I find it interesting uh
because there's no end goal for him now
right like you had a business it got
destroyed so now if you thought your
business was serving your community it's
gone and also you don't have a way to
make money so why would you go to this
length to try and appeal to a mob that
doesn't care about you um I'm thinking
about Nike still and Nike at one point
earlier this year offered to pay police
themselves to protect theirs that's
right that was in the story and Portland
was like oh you can't actually power
please we don't have enough of them we
don't have enough and also you can't do
that we don't want you to we defunded
our police and now not only do our
police have less budget but no one wants
to be one because that was the way the
defund the police movement was so
successful is no one wants to be a cop
now so there's a lot of resignations
and no one wants to join us I want to
read some of this from the story one
tweet said is quote please know whose
Windows you're breaking such a bad take
though I think there's a distinction to
be made between removing statues and
breaking windows at a museum or am I
missing some perspective
cider man says just because you're doing
a better job now than you've done in the
past doesn't exclude you from a little
bit of Reckoning doesn't demand it
either but windows are windows no my
friend windows are a symbol of our
security and safety and prosperity
because before you would have walls and
when we started putting up thin windows
that could be shattered with a rock
sitting right in front of it that was a
sign that we were honorable and secure
and we were not concerned that you could
easily make your way into my building
and steal everything I own there are
there are coffee at Starbucks for
instance yo come on Starbucks windows I
don't know I don't know maybe Starbucks
buys bulletproof windows but most
windows are easily broken and that means
we shifted as a society towards lowering
our security to a great degree because
we trust each other and we function
together and these people exploit our
Goodwill with death and destruction and
they just windows or windows then let's
go back to putting up walls windowless
stores how about that brick not just
that but like with the with the little
with the little slits so that we can
shoot out at them little panels for
self-defense yeah like they did with the
castles
yeah
the murder holes yeah but only only in
self-defense and in extreme cases where
you're under threat if you vote for the
right people if you vote for them the
arrow slits I think yeah that's what I
was thinking of this feels like when you
when you like qualify with a mob and
when you like justify mob tactics and
buy silent mob tactics it's like um
someone that's like oh like Grizzly
manage you ever see that movie where
he's like yeah it's a bear just don't
worry about it I know how to love it
it'll be different this time and then
the bear turns and eats him of course
the bear is gonna eat you I didn't get
too graphic about how he was devoured
but it wasn't face first it was from the
other direction oh so he was like alive
being consumed yes usually that's how
bears and wolves do it each alive why
don't they go for the soft bits first
like the eyes they go for the butthole
first oh good gravy
wolves wolves 100 I I imagine that's
true yeah that's what Rogan told me Joe
Rogan said that he isn't a wildlife
expert
but like you can't I mean you trust
dirty divisive untrustworthy and violent
mob tactics I don't trust Bears or
Wolves yeah to be like trusting a wild
animal kind of mobs ain't trustworthy
she didn't trust anyone no and they
don't care like they don't that's what I
care about your little middle class
lifestyle where you want to advocate for
everybody to be yeah wild predators try
to eat the butthole first first yeah why
there's so much flavor soft I guess I
guess it is right into the colon where
there's like partially digestive food
and stuff yikes and then they go just
all the way up yeah
no I can't I don't want to imagine that
well this guy's building is being this
guy's off he got eaten by the butthole
okay his business is being devoured
butthole first yeah he like took his
pants off and bent over for them he was
like yes please yeah do you like mice
put like some hot sauce on it he was
like no no it's good because if I if I
offer to you guys won't do this to me I
mean this is like the strangest part of
virtue signal culture at all which is
like if I virtue single heart if I tell
you that I'm on your side enough nothing
bad will happen to me because I'm on the
right side of history and that's not the
case at all I hope this lesson is taken
that if you diminish law enforcement in
your area that will slowly deplete the
economic value of your area and then
your business if your business it will
slowly and then very quickly deplete the
entire area it's like nobody studied the
French Revolution no you know like
doesn't doesn't everyone know like you
can't control the mob it doesn't matter
how much you say they're on that you're
on their side like oh we don't like the
king either okay well your head's going
in the basket too have fun with that
people you would think that people would
know that stuff but they don't I went to
school in the United States and a lot of
kids just didn't pay attention
in 2020 they were telling me I didn't
know anything about history but it's
like you didn't pay attention to
anything in history classic I know you
didn't but no I was there I watched you
yes stupider and stupider yeah so uh cat
feline Predators Lions
they they don't eat the stomachs go for
the liver because the stomachs contain
vegetation they can't digest so they
discard it and then uh they go through
this through the gut yeah but but yeah a
lot of animals like uh wolves and and
vultures will go through the butt
because they can pull out your guts
ow
well that's good
thanks for that one Ian yeah I feel like
I did learn something really nice though
I'm actually glad you told me that I
haven't seen Grizzly Man yet Werner
Herzog told Grizzly man's mom not to
watch it oh you know the story yeah I
know the story well and that's why I've
never seen the film The guy and his
girlfriend spent time with the woods
with the Bears and then eventually when
the camera was on but the lens cap was
covering it you hear them both get
devoured in real time
screaming and him being like help me oh
this guy's awful oh yeah the guy who was
living with the Bears right yeah that's
what his girlfriend go around living
with Bears I mean there's a reason that
we live in little towns and the bears
live over there in the woods and when
the Bears come down the street like a
bear came down my street the other day
and I heard about it and I was like I'm
glad I was in the house yeah they can
have my trash I'm staying over here in
the house we went to the Outer Banks
yeah North Carolina and there's an area
where you can go to see alligators and
turtles and bears it was really cool we
saw turtles that were like this big like
30 year old Turtles a snap Snapper was
probably 30 years old but then we saw
two black bears and uh one of them was
20 feet from the car from the road
people pull their cars over I just got
it and started taking pictures they're
like professional professional nature
photographers and this black bear
massive like wow like it it's big I've
seen black bears you know you know all
over the place this guy was massive and
he was chilling walking real slow and
then stopped and just sat for about 10
feet from a line of cars and just
watched him I posted a picture and I was
like bear seems fake AF like it it
seriously looked like a guy in a suit
like two guys in a suit like that zoo in
China
for real no I don't know I'm not gonna
accuse him of anything it was a real
bear though that the thing yeah I
remember going to Great Adventure Safari
in New Jersey and uh I was driving
around with my mom and I said I was
little and I was like Mom what are those
kangaroos doing and she was like oh my
god look away
try to jump over here I used to walk
through my yard that's when I like when
I was in high school and stuff and there
was one like it was very weird because
you would see the bear and cubs one year
and then next year the Cubs were
slightly bigger and I have much younger
siblings so we used to like have to send
them out with air horns to play in the
yard because you just don't know when
the Bears are going to be there and
they're not going to be there I gotta
but you can't just keep kids inside all
day when I was in sixth grade thank you
that was my real upbringing yeah I was
in sixth grade we went on a field trip I
can't remember which we went to it was
one of the ones in Chicago and uh we
went to look at the baboons
and the bad one of the baboons okay wait
earmuffs
for parents yeah you don't want your
kids to listen I mean it's not that it's
not that it's not that gross it's gross
though but I don't think it's that
inappropriate but anyway one of the
baboons is just sitting there and we're
all looking over the edge and then the
baboon shoves his fingers up his ass and
pulls out you know dang matter and then
looks at it sniffs his hand and then
smears it on the ground and all the kids
are watching my teacher freaks I was
like Dad don't look don't look it's like
we've seen it all you can't it's too
late she was like if one of you does
this in class
yeah it was funny baboons are gross are
the baboons with the rainbow butts yeah
I don't like those guys what's up with
that yeah they're they don't want to
mess with them they're just one uncanny
you know why baboon rainbow butt have
you seen the video where there was like
uh during covid there's no tourists so
there's no food and then someone threw
like a Snickers bar and then all of them
like run and go for it it's crazy yeah
you don't mean nobody was feeding them
well so like normally there are tourists
throwing things that eat the garbage
with no tourists there's no food right
and that's also why like the rats came
out in New York City they were
everywhere oh yeah just like huge groups
running around because they were like
there's no food anymore we better go
find it crazy we better go attack people
I've seen some creepy rats in New York
rats are creepy in New York remember
Pizza rat that was real Pizza rat yeah
what was that you like found a slice of
pizza on the subway
yeah yeah just needed a snack you guys
are so mean to him I saw I saw a
squirrel doing that once it was awesome
it was just holding a huge slice of
pizza and I was like yeah I saw a tick
tock or a seagull going into a whole
food yeah pulling a sandwich
okay and then it waits for the doors and
then someone tries to run up to it and
it's like for it but then afterwards
someone else is like no you shouldn't
have a sandwich and it's like dude leave
me alone well if you're a seagull and
you know how to steal a sandwich from
Whole Foods there's a sandwich there's a
video of a seagull walking there's like
a grocery store with like a bodega and
the doors open and the Eagle walks in
grabs a bag of chips and walks out
probably because the seagull recognized
the bag saw it on the ground sure saw
the food in it saw it and they're like
hey that's where it is the seagull
probably wasn't thinking I'm stealing
the seagull was thinking like oh look
another bag the seagull doesn't
understand currency right it was just
literally food it's just operating in
the system that he thinks we have
created for it
the elephants figured out did you see
the video of the elephant eating
stopping the the car that's driving with
all the sugar cane on it and it like
walks out on the road and blocks it and
then grabs sugarcane off the truck the
videos are really smart yeah the videos
of bears breaking into houses and they
like open the fridge and look around
like they know you have something in
there oh yeah but not stealing you can't
charge them no you can't arrest a bear
first off the Optics would be awful one
of the one of the cruel uh uh realities
of of life is that you can't cuddle with
a bear right yeah because you look at
him and you're like it's like a gigantic
dog just fluffy but it will kill you
yeah it's like a poisoned Berry it's
like you want to eat like so good but
you can't yeah like delicious mushrooms
well that's another one of those movies
remember that guy who like was in Alaska
it was another sort of in the wild into
the wild okay they ate the wrong berries
and they found them way later Emil
Hirsch yeah yeah but now with that shot
doesn't happen I think so there's a
McCandless I think which is actually
there's a canvas there's an app called
picture this that you can scan a plant
and I'll tell you what it is that's
smart I was thinking the last few days
about how horrible would be to be killed
by a non-human animal like what a waste
of life like how just what a lame ending
it would be if it was like some cheap
non-human got me like this all this
hello I was thinking like a bear human
yeah like people are just killed by an
animal yeah like a wolf or like a tiger
like how much
how much hatred like we've been so
desensitized from people getting killed
by wild animals that we don't really
fear them but like you should they don't
care yeah they don't care about you
really really should they don't have
them they don't we I don't think people
are wild animals I don't think they they
understand the horror that could come
along with like coming up on a wolf or a
bear oh I'm like terrified of wild
animal that movie cocaine bear came out
and people were like yes seems awful oh
it did yeah okay so they they need to be
fragandized people yeah they're like
scared of people and animals I've been
so much in the politics like oh it's
human versus human and politics all
these humans what if World War III and
all the human human and then I'm like
dude real talk like we were starting
against tigers for most of our existence
I am pretty afraid of ants did you ever
see that movie ants
where they're like working in the
Grasshoppers or oppressing them no oh no
no no no no A Bug's Life this is a
totally different oh I show my Bug's
Life
no no this is not an animated film it's
a scary film I remember watching it on
Cinemax no I never heard of this right
so there was a construction site and
this woman is like in her bed of course
because you have to have a naked woman
in Bed on Cinemax and she's like in her
bed and suddenly there's ants coming in
and the Ants swarm her and eat her alive
this is ants it happened at Lakewood
Manor I don't know what it was called it
was on Cinemax I was eight years old I
have no real idea I just remember this
and I remember the I remember the
visuals I remember the lighting it had
that sort of like 70s American Cinema
yellow you know that like yellow oh yeah
yeah it looked like that news you can
use the brown and she was like ah like
that and also being swarmed by bees like
being stung to death would just be all
no not me wasps
these are good people like so we have a
cherry tree and when it block when it
when it comes into bloom or whatever
it's a uh what is it it's a I don't know
yeah it's cherry tree so it does a
cherry blossom it's crazy and then it's
you can hear loud buzzing there's so
many bees
Bee's got no beef you walk right past
them you can like wave and they're like
yo what up yeah it's the WASP that chase
you down no they're mean those are mean
I don't know if they really are
me I don't get them on the show
they're inquisitive they'll fly down
right in front of your face really
aggressively and stare at you and then
they'll fly off yeah and if you freak
out then they might freak out but
they're like aggressively patrolling no
I got stung over the summer by like a
hornet or yellow deck or something on my
finger and it started to swell it took
like 24 hours and then it was so itchy
but if you itch it it then as I learned
goes down the rest of your hand and I it
it I can't imagine if you had like a
thousand of them descend on you and then
you're in pain but also you begin to
itch and itching only makes it worse it
seems like a nightmare what did you do
to treat it baking soda like water okay
my mind not chamomile uh and then I just
tried to not scratch it I wore gloves
several days what's that never mind
Calamine thank you I don't know what I'm
talking about nobody I was like I was
like thinking like oh did you just brew
a bunch of tunes
and I was thinking like this is some
sort of picture interesting rural home
remedy from Hannah Claire the Bears in
my yard told me about it that's what I
was thinking and then she brewed some
dandelion tea and the colors were
amazing I wish no that wasn't it uh I
will say I think it depends on where you
live because I think when you're saying
like if you live in a city and you're
not interact with animals maybe you
don't think about them but if you live
in a rural area and you hike a lot the
first question I get all the time is
what happens if we run into a bear and
that's a legitimate question in a lot of
areas uh the same thing with do you
bring like a shotgun or something like
what do you I do nothing I go unprepared
but I know I like to hike with people
who will bring will go armed another
reason we should support the two-way
guys they're always the first people to
think I will come with a gun just in
case uh or somebody else
can you imagine
I would love to hike with a two-way
person who can shoot down Owasso we got
these amazing water guns this summer and
they basically shoot water like it's
Buckshot
yeah sprays water but it doesn't spray
it like it like turns every little
droplet into like a bead does it hurt
yes oh wow so when you get shot with it
you're like ah and then even once you're
soaked you don't want to get shot with
it because it hurts water is a drill
yeah it's like one of the the best
drills known to man yeah the water
pressure yeah you can cut I watch
almonds just look at the Grand Canyon
high pressure water watch those videos
on Instagram where they like they put a
screwdriver and then the water slices
the screwdriver in half no way metal and
everything crazy yeah
coming out of a river the other day did
you see that it was like it was like
some stupid Instagram thing you know but
it was like a water spout did you see it
was like some Russian River it was like
flooding and stuff and yeah and it just
like went up into the sky yeah there's a
thing that happens uh over the Great
Lakes when there's like a tornado it
sucks the water up and then drops it or
something like this do it like a big
splash like like a 12-foot wave will
like slam over the wow over the highway
or whatever that's cool yeah it's like a
mini tsunami unless you're on the
highway then it's very bad I mean not
really you get splashed by water and
you're like wow that was crazy it's an
interesting real life Disney ride you
have like a water spout forms I could be
wrong about this this is what I I'm
growing up in Chicago so they say
because you're driving on Lake Shore
Drive you get really close to the water
sometimes and uh if there's like a water
spout somewhere it can pull water back
and then drop it or something like that
I don't know is it just like a water
tornado yeah and it pulls water up or
something like it sucks it up
you know and then that sounds kind of
cool yeah that's not cool weather
science is crazy well that's why we need
guns to protect ourselves from wild
animals that was my I think we need guns
to protect ourselves from the weather
climate change right we need lasers to
defend against wasps and raindrops
actually a good laser might actually
protect you from uh a wasp like a an
array of lasers that could shoot like
nine beams at once that has Auto
tracking and targeting no we're like
doctors I mean they have those lasers
that can light a match at or pop a
balloon I imagine if you pointed that at
a a bug the bug would not be very happy
no yeah I mean you can also just use
like ax body spray in a lighter but you
know no that's that you can't control
that well enough with the lights just
like point it and then the bug might
just fall off like a wall but the ax
body spray method is more fun and
terrifying when you're up yeah but very
dangerous okay yes don't do it it's bad
this is big too because there's like uh
with all the wildfires that have been
happening all over the place it's really
this is really crazy it rains at Burning
Man it was it was it was flooding in
Vegas a couple times and then out here
we haven't gotten rain in a minute it
rained last night for like the first
time in a while uh and then but we went
through a couple weeks like without any
rain we got hit them I think yeah we got
we got told that it was really dry and
so there was a high risk of fires but
now we're gonna get a ton of storms
because of all the Hurricanes coming up
I think the the Storm at Burning Man
which one predicted is just God testing
the pagans I think that he's like how
how much do you like testing I think a
lot of people believe that like truly
believe I fundamentally I was talking
about this with Liz wheeler last week I
think that uh he's not happy with them
and he thinks you know if you guys are
gonna put up what was it the chapel of
Apple at the beginning we'll just see
they also put up like a big like a big
uh you know praise Ukraine thing God's
unhappy about it that's all I have to
say what's amazing is that they're
they're Pagan peace loving War mongers
it's there's something about being
enlightened and then going to be
enlightened with other people that are
enlightened as opposed to going
somewhere completely unenlightened just
going somewhere to seek Enlightenment
and I think a lot of people are going to
burning man because they want to become
enlightened not because they are I think
they want to be able to say burning man
they want to seem cool but they are
actually not interested I mean no one
has been douchey since the 90s I don't
want to speak like ubiquitously there
are probably some people there who are
seeking Enlightenment whatever else but
I think the majority of people are going
it's it is you know the Coachella of you
know non-musical Gathering I could see
how God would Smite that people yeah
like if that's what I'm saying I think
he was unhappy I don't think he's
smiting it I just think he's like let's
see how committed you are to this bit
team and the Jeep stuck in the mud that
can never get out because it turns to
concrete she's gonna be like an auto
grave right graveyard Cadillac Ranch out
and I think it's near Amarillo Texas
have you gone a bunch of times I've been
once once in 2008 yeah how was it it was
awesome yeah I took mushrooms for like
seven days straight we had a big bag and
I just walk around and every time they'd
start the the high would start to change
I'd come back and eat some more and keep
walking and it was start your day like
three in the afternoon because the
sunlight you want to kind of miss the
sun and then you're up till like 7 A.M
every day it's it's an all-night party
just blasting music and lights not this
year psychedelics and that's it no nope
take a bike you just drop it on the
ground and keep walking find another
bike pick it up and use it it's it's
cool it's terrible it's it's cool if
you're single and you want to take a lot
of psychedelics that's about it I'd just
be pissed if somebody kept stealing my
bike
yeah there's no stealing everything you
take there is going to be taken just
sounds terrible so don't take your phone
it'll probably gonna take it might it
might get sand damage too so you're
gonna watch out for sand damage on any
equipment you're taking and you got to
wear masks right because all the Alkali
dust yeah yeah but like good sealant
masks because the dust you'll get these
white out storms will kick on and you
won't be able to see further than like
three feet in front of yourself it
sounds like pure hell yeah it's all
about psychedelics maybe people go and
don't do psychedelics and they're just
like it's the experience
rich people with private planes who fly
in and bring have RVs deliver then put
up stages and they're like cool like
dude do it somewhere else climate
protesters Extinction Rebellion went out
there stopping up traffic people don't
realize they literally have like an
airport there like they land planes
outside there and then they go into like
this own little hermetically sealed tent
it's not like it's not what everyone
thinks it is it's like super glamping
yeah it literally is literally dude
you'll be walking and it'll be like just
desert black like dust and dark and then
there will be a building and you're like
what the is this and you walk up to
it like a bunch of walk in and it's like
a bar fully set up like I wonder if this
one was a vampire bar they had vials of
blood around their neck they were like
grinding on the stage they had filed
their teeth and they were taking
people's weapons why did God not Smite
this suit it was like dark and red it
was like smoky in there like what does
this exists and everyone had they had to
give their weapons if anyone had like a
character was carrying I don't think I
don't know what kind of weapons and then
would other people just pick them up and
keep moving just like with the bike oh I
didn't see what happened but I had a
flashlight on me a really bright one and
they didn't take it and I felt like a
Jedi like they didn't see my lightsaber
as a weapon because if if it hit the fan
I had something to blind people within
the dark I felt like I was like armed
yeah I felt it was kind of cool feeling
yeah especially when you have people who
are filing their teeth and drinking
blood it was nuts people like that
really exist well you know you know
that's like part of the there's like
this um
where is it in Africa and they have this
like the big Salt Flats and everything
and people like mine salt and their
teeth get really soft and they they can
file them down
and that's wild teeth freaked me out I'm
sorry I got a dentist appointment
tomorrow yeah it actually hasn't been
bad at all I was avoiding it for years
and years because the pain and now I'm
like dude it's pain is temporal it comes
and goes we're gonna go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member uh we're
gonna have a fun conversation in about a
half an hour on the uncensored show
talking about
well talking about the history of 9 11.
and uh talking about the the origins uh
the causes the aftermath and uh we're
gonna get into the nitty-gritty so it's
going to be really really fun I hope to
uh I hope you guys join and come hang
out for this conversation and we're
going to take your questions as well so
I hope you got some good ones
culture abduction says first a comment
before that Buddy Guy dude happy Monday
y'all you got it you won yeah they won
good job what do we got impassable says
Tim did you see that they ruled the way
they were validating balance was illegal
Carrie Lake essentially won essentially
carry like one
there's a bunch of different things you
could win want to battle not the war but
uh yeah that's a that's a big story
actually uh the a judge ruled that the
way they've been handling it is not
legal in 2020 and 2022 so um wow good
job Kerry Lake I don't know what that
means for her but it's good that she's
getting these reforms uh these things
rolled on
let's grab another Super Chat and we'll
move on
Stephen says happy birthday Libby may
you have many more thank you I
appreciate it
fix bayonet says we need to start
looking at voter registration around
military bases while I was in many
soldiers did not vote and if they were
registered it was in their home state
interesting that's interesting too
because in Ukraine zielinski who said
that you um can't have an election
uh while there's a war going on said
that he would consider having an
election next year if the U.S and Europe
paid for the election and made sure that
everyone in the military and everyone
who's not in Ukraine right now could
vote he said he only needs five
bazillion I think it was actually five
billion or something like that it's a
cheap price for him yeah he's like I've
asked her so much more this is nothing
yeah yeah considering we are his tax
base now so yeah makes sense we work
really hard so that the government can
take our money and send it to Ukraine
what a weird place where your democracy
is contingent on if the US government
will pay for it later
yeah that's a good deal here's one Joe
Spinell says Tim I'm going to come out
of the gate and say watch Deep Space
Nine episodes past tense part one and
two now this aired in 1995 but the date
in these episodes occur August 30th 2024
and hit too close to home just finished
watching them again uh I'll go check it
out maybe I'll watch it tonight for
those that are wondering
I'll give you the quick uh uh gist of it
so uh Commander Cisco Dr Bashir and
Jadzia Dax these are good episodes yeah
they uh beam Down to Earth but
accidentally materialized in 2024
they're found by police officers who
believe them to be vagrants get them off
the streets and escort them to a
sanctuary District a waldorf ghetto to
contain the poor the sick and the
mentally disabled and anyone else who
can't support themselves
so they've arrived just before the bells
Riots of violent confrontation in the
sanctuary District I'll leave it there
but
yet it took place uh
nowish apparently yeah I will say Avery
Brooks I think is one of the best
captains Captain Cisco he's he's I think
he will take that bold political stance
I think I think you like him more than
Cisco is my favorite more than the
Patrick Stewart he's good genre though
he's not a captain yeah because he
becomes a captain he becomes a captain
Cisco's good I like Picard a lot I don't
like Picard anymore I do too you don't
no really why because of where Patrick
Stewart's gone later in life yeah well
kind of because where like because the
way that the culture in Next Generation
actually would be if you're not in
Starfleet seems incredibly oppressive
and authoritarian and also the way that
they are always expecting themselves to
conform to other cultures and like wear
the weird hats and whatever but they
always act like those other cultures are
beneath them
you know and that like oh we in
Starfleet we don't have any Gods because
we are perfect we are perfect human
beings we don't need money we don't need
anything we're just going to
you know exist in this way I don't like
it I like the timeline where Trump gets
elected and then Earth becomes the
Terran Empire and goes to war and wipes
everybody out that sounds really fun I
didn't I actually skipped that was but I
I'm I'm half kidding but uh I guess the
second season of Picard was like they
have to go back in time and stop Trump
from getting elected or something like
that really I watched the third season
after they finally I got the band back
together and went back out on tour I'm
glad they first one was was okay third
one was good I skipped the second one I
skipped a second too because I think I I
could be wrong but I think the general
idea is not literally Trump but like the
trump-esque character yeah Q shows up
and he's like look Picard I'm old now
because I'm trying to look like you and
it's like we get it dude you're you're
John Delancey is an old guy and then uh
he's like I'm gonna create change time
and make it so that Trump won the
election and then like they live in an
oppressive Nazi regime or something
something like that yeah and like Picard
is like some kind of I don't know ex
yeah some warlord or something I
couldn't watch it I just stopped not
interested all right who owns it
Golden Fleece game says governor of New
Mexico committed a felony Title 18
section 242 she should be charged with
one count per citizen who lives in the
affected jurisdictions and anyone who
travels through there agreed but first
she should be impeached removed from
office and then criminally indicted
all right carry case is Happy Birthday
Libby it's my birthday too happy
birthday I'm almost halfway to 100 now
yay nice happy birthday and uh someone
mentioned Butters from South Park his
birthday is also September 11th nice
yeah so all good company
what a birthday party that would be I
mean there are a lot of days that live
in infamy you know but I mean imagine
being born on September 11th 2001 like
that'd be pretty someone is right right
but also you don't care because your
entire life would be after 9 11. you'd
be like you would you would care though
because every year on your birthday for
your whole life people would be making
it a big deal and you wouldn't have a
birthday what if you were born in New
York City on September like 11 2001.
that's crazy and you can't have birth
like it for for a while like you don't
have normal birthdays I haven't had a
normal birthday since then yeah I had a
normal birthday that year because my
friend was uh my best friend she wasn't
around Tuesday night because she had to
work so we went out on Monday night and
we had a really fun time and that was my
last normal birthday ever since then
I've been like it's my birthday we don't
have to go for drinks it's okay
hey we got a good one Spartan bacon says
Tim since you mention us a lot here is
some money to celebrate Nebraska's
constitutional carry taking effect last
week uh last weekend wow that is awesome
glad to hear it man
yeah Quantum strange Quark says Libby
and Butters from South Park share a
birthday wow congratulations that's
funny
Morgan Estill says I was at the protest
in Albuquerque on Sunday in full armor
with an AR oh wow how'd it go there's
another armed protest tomorrow in
Albuquerque at Civic Plaza downtown 10
a.m to 6 p.m local time spread the word
Tim well you just did so uh you spread
the word uh thanks for Super Chat
what do we have what do we have
Wrath of Paul says if you allow the
government to break the law during an
emergency they will create an emergency
to break the law
as it goes
yep
oh look at this Savage man since it's my
birthday too happy birthday Olivia hey
happy birthday
apparently a lot of people are born
every day this is true breaking news
that's true yeah what's that there's
like this interesting math thing about
uh if there's like 25 people in a room
the likelihood you share a birthday is
like 78 or something ridiculous number
yeah because it's really one in 365. so
it's not really that you know
statistically incredible honestly 1-365
is pretty small but you'd think in order
to share a birthday you need
700 something people
uh yeah I forget what it is
um what the actual number is but yeah
still you would need two people to have
born on the same day so if you had one
person born on every day you'd need
another group of people born every
single day but then well actually no
because then everyone would share a
birthday yes yeah
also like the odds that you would have
that everyone that 365 people would all
have a different birthday is also like
that doesn't seem also it's probably not
random when people are impregnated and
born I bet there's some more circadian
rhythm to it I think there is a most
common birthday what's the most common
birthday I will look it up right now I
could be wrong I especially
now I mean so many people are going
through scheduled C-sections now and I
doubt a doctor would schedule one on the
weekend so I think there must be gaps uh
every couple years of weekends weekend
yeah like yeah just go home and cross
your legs hopefully you're good
apparently uh if you have more than 23
people in a group the odds are better
than 50 50. right the two of two of them
will have a birthday Daisy says welcome
my son Wyatt Middleton born a September
11th 2023 pretty crazy birthday nice it
was an emergency C-section mum and baby
are doing great that's so wonderful
congratulations
um
this says September 16th is the most
common birthday
really so what happens nine months
before September
New Year's I guess right
that makes sense yep so on New Year's
this other one a lot of people the other
one is September has a lot of common
birthdays and that's probably why
um
because it's winter too so it gets dark
earlier
but it's New Year's yeah it's Christmas
and New Year's and you know that's
interesting it's vacation time next
holiday the family it's probably not
just news it's probably just vacation
time you've got this period after
Christmas to New Years where nobody's
doing anything and you know some people
are apparently doing stuff that's what I
mean I'm usually at my job yeah but
you know I I used to work through the
Christmas but it is like pushing a
boulder uphill
because there's a lot of arguments we'll
make what's like you get more views
during Christmas because no that's not
true dude no holidays are you work twice
as hard and you get half the half the
reach that's what I've discovered as
well yep and I think rest is actually
very important I mean there are studies
that talk about sleep and all kinds of
things lowering your cortisol is
extremely important long term so trying
to burn out during a period of time is
maybe not always worth it yeah I spend a
lot of time on YouTube the time that I
watched Elise YouTube is during the
holidays like by far just don't watch it
so
all right John Cerro sanguinius says Ray
Epps tapes Shroyer walks Shroyer walks
oh wait your government is captured
never mind yeah shout out I tweeted this
out uh during the show
Owen schroyer says that the tyrants and
you know Ian brought that point up Ray
app says literally that we have to go
into the capital and he's not even
charging anything it's so weird
they should at least charge him and give
him a slap on the wrist if he's an
informant so that people will be
satisfied at least do something they're
doing a very bad job of this conspiracy
I don't yeah it's weird
sad tooth they're doing a bad job and
yet that's enough for them it's not
working out for them yeah they don't
have to do a thing
cam girl Asuna
says eventually they will use the Sham
j6 precedence against you Tim then they
will use it against me good luck in the
corrupt courts Tim good luck complying
your way out of tyranny
he says he'll take the Bundy Ranch
approach see this is this is like fed
talk right right the people who are you
know who are like Ray apps like
literally talk about reps telling
everyone to do the thing that hurts
everything you're trying to do in the
meantime like Public Square is doing
their spec or whatever they have tons of
money they're succeeding massively all
these businesses that believe in
American values are making more money
than ever the massive success of the
Independent Media space is through the
roof Joe Rogan despite all their
attempts to try and take him down it's
just bigger and and better than ever
every day there's a new story about
something he's done you've got Bud Light
crumbling you've got Target failing you
it's just across the board victory
victory victory the governor of New
Mexico and Desperation signs this decree
everyone immediately ignores and it's
just like man how much do you have to be
winning to be like let's throw it all
away and just act like sporadically and
randomly it's it's just crazy
yep but uh while we're we're looking at
an active conflict there's a challenge
that every generation faces you know
every generation has their challenge we
we think that things are bad it's like
well you know the fear of nuclear
Annihilation existed during the Cold War
you had 70 years of that kind of fear
but I'm just like
look man I think we win this one but I
think we're we're in a conflict and so
we have to
play strategically incorrectly and that
is
do what we're doing man starting
businesses challenging the machine they
want to get rid of Angie Terence
Williams makes cousin tease take them
over Hollywood goes woke the daily wire
comes right on in
they if they want to walk away from
these mountains where their King on the
unthrone or whatever let them do it yeah
this writers strike and actors strike
thing in Hollywood is not being
effective at all
I keep forgetting that they're on strike
there's so much content out there to
look at has anybody watch no and Drew
Barrymore just said that she was going
to bring her show back just without the
writers oh wow yeah that'll be terrible
yeah I mean it'll probably be the same
to me that's what I mean like yeah it's
terrible either way it's like yeah sure
she doesn't need yeah she doesn't need
writers she can use AI to write I don't
know I mean she could probably write it
herself I mean what's to write yeah
literally what's to write like just go
on a little rant to have something to
say bring your guest on suddenly all the
guests all the guests will suddenly have
like way less interesting stories
well the way that they're doing it is
she's saying we'll have guests on but we
just won't talk about we just won't
promote their projects so that we're
still complying with the writer strike
which is going to be more interesting
because no one wants to hear about
people promoting their movies anyway
that's the boring part of the interview
yeah I think the writers strike is
probably going to backfire to a certain
degree because I remember the writers
strike back in like was like 2007 or
whatever was that one I noticed yeah we
all noticed Heroes got got ruined yeah
we're all excited like wow what a good
show and then season two happened with
the writer strike and it was like the
show's awful now yeah really bad oh 708
November 5th is when it started 2007.
and nobody's noticed the writer strike
no it went for four months well and even
the late night hosts are like we're
gonna do podcasts now since we can't do
the show we're gonna do podcasts and
we'll give any Revenue to our writers
who are on strike but we're still going
to go do work yeah so but like their
podcast is really bad oh I haven't
listened to it because it's short it's
terrible because these people don't
actually have anything to say so it's
literally them being like I'm me and
you're you are you you I'm me and you're
you wow Jimmy Kimmel Stephen Stephen
Colbert hey what about you Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon and it's it's all they're
doing and you can you get to watch the
tone listen to their tone and like how
annoyed the alpha it's like you can see
the alpha the Dynamics of who's the
alpha Stephen Colbert supposed to be
like the leader and the other guys can't
stand him or they you can sense the
annoyance and to be honest I just saw
one clip and Seth Meyers was extremely
disgusted with what he had to say and do
he did not look like he wanted to be
there but like it's funny to watch their
their emotional Dynamics change when
they're trying to like because they're
all used to be in the alpha yeah I'm
gonna say if you were the host of a late
night show and now we have multiple
hosts of a late night show being hosted
by a host with nothing to talk about I
mean but I do think Dave Letterman and
Johnny Carson would be funny and throw
in Conan that would have been a funny
podcast those guys earned those on Merit
these new guys those guys were funny
sorry to interrupting oh I was gonna say
the same thing they were funny and the
people now are just used to being told
well you're hilarious please say this
monologue that probably someone else has
written there's not a skill I also think
you can probably see that there is not
actual friendship between any of them
people think anyone can start start a
podcast and anyone literally could but
not everyone should you know and this is
sort of an example they should maybe not
be podcasting they just because they
talk for a living doesn't mean they
actually have anything to say they don't
talk they read scripts for a living
exactly these people are proof that the
machine just chose people who to put on
TV and when it comes to actual Battle of
Merit they have none so I'm excited for
the next decade or so when
assuming things are going in a more
positive direction uh with like Rumble
success and Public Square meritocracy
will reign supreme and all of these
placed personalities will be struggling
let's read some more we got uh Ben D
says Wells Remy Crowther the man in the
red bandana saved 17 people above the
77th floor went back in to save more and
was never seen again
they had about an hour after the plane
hit before it came down and so
the people nobody thought that was going
to happen so they thought they were
going to be able to go in as long as
they avoided the fire and you know they
knew there was risks but
yeah man
Patriot American says 911 will always
remain a sorrowful day my dad worked
three blocks from the site until August
of 01 My Buddy lost his grandfather and
his dead in the North Tower collapsed
both FDNY I don't even know if their
bodies got recovered
yeah man mama like sadness I'm just past
sadness and anger I can't even get angry
about anymore I just want people to know
what really happened I want the evidence
to come out about the Nano thermite and
the dust just all sorts of stuff that'll
take 50 years if we're lucky that's all
I care about is that the truth comes out
what if Donald Trump gets reelected and
then he's just like we're releasing all
of the documents at 11. here it is so
bad and he just like dropped on a table
and it's just the most shocking and
craziest stuff you've ever heard he
didn't release the he didn't do anything
he didn't release the Kennedy
unclassified documents well to be fair I
think he tried but they kept just
ignoring him really yeah so like the
issue with Trump is that he would say
hey do this thing to go you got it and
then they wouldn't and then he'd forget
yeah
and we learned the least about aliens
from him to be fair the Bible
Administration has told us so much
[Laughter]
let's grab another Super Chat
Essie federale essay federally says Joe
Biden literally told Jon Stewart I tried
that they didn't buy it or I'd be
president right now and laughed about
coal mining in his family he hasn't had
dementia his entire life he's just a
compulsive liar he knows it yeah yeah he
is a compulsive liar that's why he said
that he went to Ground Zero the day
after it happened and but when it was
actually weeks after it happened
did he even go I don't know his
administration was Senate delegation on
September 20th 2001 you could check who
was in that delegation but that's that's
the congression that's the sign of a
compulsive liar that's on autopilot he
also I mean he obviously lied but he
said that he never discussed his son's
business arrangements with him
they're attempting to hide that data
because my mom being like I haven't seen
the proof like that's not a that's not
an accident that that proof hasn't been
shown on MSNBC
all right we got a bunch of happy
birthday Libby's that's very thankful
that's very kind thank you mishut says
so are you guys going to call Jimmy Dora
he two days ago on his show said
these crimes being reported in cities
are propaganda reported by can can
verbatizes convertises what's that I
don't know but that's a great typo good
job
conservatives is probably what the word
supposed yeah but it was like I don't
want to I don't want to read
conservative just because I see it
sounds similar like
advertises literally so what what did
Jimmy say I don't think he's an idiot
uh well he can be wrong I like Jimmy
he's a smart guy but we all get things
wrong that's fine if I don't know what
he said if he got something wrong I
would just be like oh hey Jimmy I think
you're wrong about that they'll say well
I I disagree on but okay you know he'll
be like okay and then we'll move on
because Jimmy's a good dude yeah being
stupid being ignorant and being wrong
are all different things yeah but
they're all allowed being a liar is not
allowed yes yeah and being a liar as
well so being a liar is allowed but we
don't like it but like when someone's
wrong and then they're called stupid or
when someone doesn't know information
and they're called wrong and it's like
no they're all very different things
it's or he's got an opinion on it you
know whatever
uh what he says the show is just
propaganda you know whatever
uh these Smash and grabs I'm hearing are
on the are happening everywhere on the
East Coast even at this point everywhere
well I I Feel Like These are probably
Interstate criminal organizations going
around doing this it's not just like you
and five friends being like let's do
this thing yeah it's gonna be pretty
organized like a
you know Oliver Twist
fagin kind of thing I mean it's as
simple as just getting much Bull on
social media and just saying hey we're
all gonna go do this this time talk on
Signal telegram whatever and then
everyone does it right everybody get a
ride yeah Michael beacon says thanks
crew now I'm going to second guess my
husky sniffing anuses oh yeah that's why
that's what it's all about man yeah
what'd you eat for dinner Rick Higby
says I was named after Rick roscorla
born 9 2101 wow that's a good name man
it's an honor oh cool yeah that story is
incredible man I I see stories like that
and I'm just thinking you know like how
do we not have a generation of people
who are raised on that story yeah who
who want to be like that that's crazy I
mean that they're Communists out there
Communists are like the antithesis of
that dude yeah you know yeah literally
everyone should be doing everything for
me and I should get stuff
yeah okay dude and you need to change
your perception of reality to suit me
they really downplayed the heroes on 911
kind of thing like they talk vaguely
about heroes of 9 11 but like
I think it's because the whole thing was
was activated I think that it has I
think that it was downplayed at first we
had a patriotic moment and then what
happened is you had an entire
Progressive wave come in and tell us
that Islamic terrorism was our fault
that we Americans deserved it that the
hate that was
um shown to us was our fault right that
we were the ones who caused the Islamic
terrorists to hate us and we got what we
deserved and we needed to go around
placating the World and Maya kulpa all
over the place to try and make people
not hate us globally and then what
happened is we started hating ourselves
because that wasn't even effective and
people still hate the great Satan of the
United States
so we went from a brief patriotic moment
where we were almost unified right even
Rhonda santis says that it was the
patriotism of that moment that caused
him to enlist and that was true for a
lot of people they enlisted after 9 11
but then once you had the Next Great
Wave come in and it was Politically
Incorrect to say that the people who you
know turned our civilian planes into
bombs hated us and were islamists
Islamic right you couldn't say that
anymore and then there was this whole
thing about like you know if you if you
say that they're Islamic terrorists what
you're doing is being racist against
Muslims in the United States and it all
got twisted around into this huge amount
of self-hatred where now we are a
self-hating nation that denies ourself
any joy and patriotism
it's sad how can you raise the whole
generation and that's and that's where
we are and now we have this insane
narcissism we have this need to uh make
everybody's perception of reality
conform to our perception of reality
right like right down to these stupid
pronouns you know
that's weird and that's where we are a
lot of it I think is the the motion of
political correctness
into progressivism it's funny how you
watch political correctness on South
Park and you see how they've had arcs
with it over like 20-year period and
then they have it come back again and
they say oh it's all happening again
because it's literally what happens it
comes back over and over again yeah and
it started in like 89. yeah let's read
this we got the Dude abides 95 says
speaking of New Mexico over here in
Illinois we had a preliminary injunction
for our assault weapons ban a few months
ago which got overturned thousands
bought arms during it and the governors
say they will not be grandfathered in
people will be criminals on October 1st
yep they keep trying
but look man there are evil States and
everyone looks to these evil States like
oh no our gun rights are being taken
away it's like in those evil States and
then there's more than half the country
where it's unrestricted yeah granted I
know NFA still exists and it's and it's
ridiculous that there's a lot of bands
on stupid things suppressors should be
you should be able to walk into a store
you shouldn't even need a background
check for a suppressor because of
because people basically I'll tell you
I'm talking to um uh Brandon Herrera on
Friday and I was explaining how in
Maryland the scar 20s is legal but an
M1A is illegal why it makes literally no
sense at all a scar 20s is like a modern
uh 308 and an M1A is like an old school
and for no reason no logical reasons so
when it comes to suppressors they're
scary because in movies they go they
don't actually do that if you're in your
home and you want Home Defense a
suppressor is a very important thing to
have but they're very very difficult to
get yep that's so you don't death in
yourself it's still super loud it's it's
still going to mess you up why what's
the what's the theory of why they would
some some polishing song movie where it
goes oh I can't let people be assassins
that's too dangerous but they literally
didn't really do that no not even close
it's still it's still Wicked loud Wicked
loud yeah like if you fired one in here
you'd be like ah like if if a gun went
off in this room you would not you would
be deaf yeah like for how long
temporarily okay you'd hear
yeah but uh or if I'm going to rock
concerts too much huh yeah but uh if
even with a suppressor it's it's loud
it's just better and so I think
um I think it was the dude from Phoenix
ammo who said this it's like it makes it
tolerable with your with if you're not
you don't have ear protection on and
you're outside okay but think about this
you're in your house someone breaks in
and you grab your gun to defend yourself
you're gonna you're gonna be deaf if you
do
like you're gonna be dead here by the
trouble too because then you can't hear
whatever else they're doing and these
are what so what do you do it's like
yourself coming to your house and you
put on your headphones and yeah it is
what it is so if if they didn't ban
things like suppressors or I shouldn't
say ban but restrict them under the NFA
people would be safer much safer
stupid stupid rules stupid rules anyway
my friends if you haven't already would
you smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends tell them all about it because
it really does help I meet so many
people every day who shout who who say
like you know they love the show and
everything and uh share with your
friends because that's that's the
marketing play these days it's it is the
Merit there is the show Good go uh head
over to timcast.com click join us
because we're going to talk about 911
and uh a lot of theories over at
thetimgas.com in about three or so
minutes we'll see you there for the
uncensored members only you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast let me do you want
to shout anything out yeah I want to
shout out thepostmillennial.com we're
doing a lot of great work there we have
some amazing writers reporters and
editors and I'd love for you to check
out what we're doing also
humanevents.com we've been putting out
some really incredible op-eds
um and stories you should come check
that out and also I want to invite you
to be members at thepostmillennial.com
subscribe
um that would be great you can help out
Independent Media and journalism and
Andino and Katie and Beth and everybody
else who's doing this great work so we'd
love to see you there and also I hope to
see you in Miami on October 6th because
that's going to be killer yeah it's
gonna be super awesome it's gonna be
just like a super cool thing everyone's
gonna be hanging out when we did the
event in New York we were walking around
and stuff so I hope you know people come
hang out I don't know
how you know Matt Gates Patrick David
and Donald Trump Jr might be a little
bit more secure to them but I think it's
like everything's just you know we'll be
hanging out it'll be fine I think
meeting like-minded people right like if
you're coming to a Tim cast event you
probably share views with other people
in the audience you should yeah so you
can build a community amongst yourselves
we are doing a uh 3 P.M Elite members
private event like lunch or something
nice it's like I have no time to eat
during the day so like this is when I
get to eat food so I'm like oh we'll do
a thing we'll have food and then I'll
get to eat and then we get to hang out
with all the elite members make sure you
get someone to get you some food so that
you don't end up talking to people the
whole time and still don't eat well it
will be like hors d'oeuvres or something
I'll I'll figure it out but uh yeah
Elite members sign up at timcast.com at
the hundred dollar a month level or
higher and as a member at any level you
get access to the Discord where there's
a pre-show and after show every night on
on the server it's really really cool
shout out to all the people on the
Discord who are running it but anyway we
should we should get to it yeah uh and I
hope all the Discord members who hang
out and talk to each other come to Miami
and meet each other in person I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writing for
timcast.com I'll also be in Miami and I
hope to see you guys all there you
should follow at timcast news on Twitter
from RX or whatever and Instagram it's
the best like Libby it's uh Independent
Media we really love post Malone's work
and we hope you support our journalists
too uh if you want to follow me
personally I'm on X at Hannah
claire.beat or no at HC brimlow and on
Instagram at handclare.b thank you guys
so much it's so fun to be here with all
of you yes I forgot my Twitter your
Twitter is at Libby Emmons thank you
follow Libby on Twitter at Libby Emmons
you're welcome and hit me up uh I hope
to see you guys at the at the Florida
event it's going to be hot get your
tickets at timcast.com there's a banner
up top you can click on the Miami
Florida October 6th event get your
tickets there uh I'm happy to be here
thank you so much for coming have a nice
evening see you later
yep Miami is gonna be cool I've been
there it's going to be sweet I hope you
guys actually do come and join us my
name is Sir dark I want to shout out
Kellen for last week for helping me
while I was ill and dying I really
appreciate that dude uh anyways let's
get to this after show and talk about 9
11 because it's changed my life that's
for sure we will see you all over at
timcast.com in a couple minutes thanks
for hanging out